mais mais il a lieu gt gt jahier pas la
date et puis voilà pas toutes les
histoires qui a ces derniers jours on
n'arrête pas d'en parler malheureusement
parce que l'actualité
l'actualité du site et des matchs nous
force à en parler mais apparemment ça se
joue quand même donc la bombe à nouveau
comme d'hab est pour ike un pas deux pas
de bluff or attend déjà effectué live
soit lancée parce que je le vois pas
alors qu'ils devraient être lancés way
nancy c'est bon c'est lancé et on va
voir on va voir ce que ça donne
or voir ce que ça donne donc bon bonjour
bonsoir à tous je vous attends dans le
chatt 1 pour bien lancer le truc je voir
si le match est parti des risques comme
les dernières fois ouais ça y est c'est
parti
on va suivre du côté de martirossian
up.fr suivre comme ça et alors là on est
une variante que j'ai déjà joué
c'est un mixte de variantes de moscou et
de cambridge spring fade anti moscou et
de cambridge fring alors je sais que
c'est pas excellent pour les noirs
j'avais analysé le truc assez loin et je
sais que les blancs peuvent être un peu
mieux mais je sais plus exactement
comment les magnifiques est il ya les
philippines sous web mais de façon il va
être déclassé magnifique chassaing
alaphilippe l'un donc mais même s'il a
levé les bras et tous ces justes qui
c'est qui va déclassé mais même si à la
télé ils te disent oui erreurs de cadets
ou quoi c'est juste que il vise pas
possible qu'ils le laissent qui le
laisse classés ouais donc c'est l'idée
de cette variante c'est de rejouer avec
b6 loubet cette c5 et deux mémoires
c'est un peu mieux pour les blancs mais
alors c'est pas énorme énorme c'est pas
énorme énorme
c'est pas énorme et n'en attendez je
vais je vais me remettre le chrono je
vais mettre le chrono jeu mais je mets
tous les trucs en place comme vous le
savez un de toute façon ça dure quatre
heures on a le temps on a bien le temps
c'est brun prend n'est pas bien sûr
évidemment je vais attendre que ce soit
17h04 allez donc c'est un poil moins
bien pour les noirs ces trucs là mais
c'est parce pas de beaucoup quoi c'est
ça va c'est ça c'est pas genre réfuter
ou quoi ça se joue
c'est dans le domaine du jouable quoi
c'est dans le domaine du jouable bon
elle se fout qu'un peu moins bien mais à
la case de 4 pour un cavalier et on peut
jouer b4 pour attaquer le cavalier c3
surtout en blitz quoi ils ont en longue
peut-être tu peux tu peux bien de faire
vis et parfois mais mais faire un truc
assez précis et la salaire de tout à
fait aller fait cavalier de dons qu'ils
anticipent les tours ces huit baies
quatre martyrs aux enfants à moi je suis
à fond pour martirossian 1
je suis à fond pour martirossian perso
bras vous faites ce que vous voulez mais
à moi je suis complètement pour
martirossian quoi mais j'espère bien
qu'il va gagner
aller en finale et peut-être même badge
et frictions qu'en finale 1 pourquoi pas
hein
soyons fous soyons fous
soyons même complètement fou j'ai pas
vous si vous êtes pour martirossian ou
pas mais vous pouvez être pour quelqu'un
d'autre un mémoire c'est sûr que vous ne
ferez pas changé d'avis je vous le dis
tout de suite un miel car d'être un peu
fatigué qui se grattent les yeux après
ça ça l'arrangé un peu un que ça joue
une heure plus tôt à mon avis le match a
commencé
du coup là c'est parti
et puis ça va jouer pendant quatre
heures pour être bien sûr que le plus
fort gagne
il a battu guéant nommé yang guillon qui
jouent en 2002 main contre sarah n'a
mais il devrait gagner facile il devrait
gagner face ils vraiment gagné très
facilement même extrêmement facilement
bref au v8 bon allez c'est toujours
pareil hein s'effacer structure de 2,9 à
rendre des chances de la slave
c'est vraiment structure vendent des
changes de la slave sahara n'a bien trop
fort c'est extraordinaire mais tu as
raison et saada bien trop fort mais sur
le temps pour ça échange je vais essayer
de pas trop gris d'énergie sur le
commentaire de ce match là pour rester
un peu en forme un pur pour mvl tout à
l'heure contre gries tchouk jinder
bringing up qui lui aussi à fond pour
martirossian non mais oui enfin je pense
tout à fait normal d'être à fond pour
martirossian en fait tout le monde doit
être à fond pour martirossian ici je ne
comprends pas comment être pour un autre
joueur autant on est à fond pour
l'équipe d'arménie à la dernière fois à
quoi toujours toujours toujours ségara
début de l'année alors j'ai pas trop
compris j'ai pas trop compris
honnêtement j'ai pas trop compris je
vous le dis franchement c'est difficile
de comprendre comment ça va jouer j'ai
on m'a pas donné les règles
le seul truc que je peux dire c'est que
j'étais sensé commenter sur cette chaîne
mais bon j'ai dit que voilà on suivait
un nouvel tranquille entre nous et que
si on le faisait ici aurait personne ce
que les gens vont penser qu'à le speech
est junior avant et tout quoi
donc c'est ça va être problématique quoi
alaphilippe même pas disqualifié et
c'est fou parce qu'il a vraiment quand
tu vois le sprint je les ai revus la
juste avant de lancer le la et vit pas
ça ralentit la vraiment gêné marquier
chien il l'a vraiment gêné effet il a il
a complètement bloqué en fait c'est
impossible qu'ils soient pas disqualifié
enfin disqualifié fini dernier de son
groupe quoi prince étonnant s'il est pas
disqualifié faut faire gaffe de ne pas
se prendre au gardien trucs marrants ces
cavaliers eu cinq attaques dames c'est
cette défend et dames b4 samata c'est
joli ça m'a t d mais c'est mignon voilà
je vous le montre au moins ça fait
toujours plaisir les petits mater des
moi j'aime bien en tout cas
mais voilà bon là est ce qui fait d'un
b4 kébé 3 il va il va perdre la première
à notre petit ait là ou pas cavalier à 4
pas mal il s'en prend pions b2 il va
remettre le roi au 8 mai toujours au
même problème du foot est certain c'est
toujours la même chose
mial on le voit calculé quelque chose il
ya un truc marrant c'est que si tu fais
un coupon lambda n'y a pas beaucoup de
coups lambda mais admettons à trois
cavaliers prend b2 qui a réalisé cinq
échecs dames france et 5 et sur dame
français 5e rang des 3 et cavalli
reprend c'est marrant ça c'est marrant
ça on vite fait mais voilà c'est une
petite bombinette petites combines est
sympa donc avalé à 4 jouer menace qui
prend b2
atteint menace autre qui prend b2
quoique sûr qu'il prend b2 key c5 dame
prend ya peut-être cavaliers cinq échecs
intermédiaire protège le fouet dame
reprend ses cinq ça marche pas tout à
fait il a fait fou prend v5 d'un pro b 5
prises b5 et sur fous ces six cavaliers
5 3 des 6 il doit vouloir dame bk 3
c'est cette crise et 6,3 à ses six dames
prend 1,4 pour ceux qui ont suivi
en gros ont réussi à supprimer le
défenseur et a pas se faire prendre par
la dame en croit des huit dames prend à
4 et là c'est complètement gagnant 1 ses
deux pions de plus ea il ya toujours le
mauvais fou j'allais voir mikit a rien à
perdre avec une grosse marche pour le
bordel ça ferait pas bon pour eux
souffraient le bordel si paire d as non
moi je suis pour qu'ils gagnent moi je
veux qu'ils gagnent le speech et juniors
ah non moi je suis à fond pour je suis à
fond pour martirossian depuis le début
c'est pas sympa pour commencer à être
compte maintenant 1
alors maintenant peut-être dame baies 5
pouces et 6 tams et 5 non chiffrée dame
c5 ici de forcer les changes des dames
jordan b1 dames c'est un nom qui fleure
dame b qu'adam c5 maintenant en vrai ce
qui paraît être le plus simple pour
gagner puisque sans les dames sans les
dames il a quand même deux pions liés en
plus donc sûrs adams et cinq dames b1 et
là à là il veut dame b 1 dames c'est un
et il y aura aidé à me prends à 2 mais
il ya dame ces six échecs c'est pour ça
qu'il a mille euros 8 c'était ça tout
l'idée bas et c'est bien joué de la part
de niall dame f5
donc c'est pour ça qu'il n'a pas fait
d'amis berne ce que dame maire
d'amsterdam à deux dames ces six échecs
dames f5 et hay qui veut fou b5
maintenant dont il fait food et c'est ce
qu'ils vont nous empêcher dams et 8
et ici est ce qu'il va faire broyer
fuite à ils passent par là bas d'accord
il veut tenter foulée 5 da machin maths
mais c'est là qu'on voit qu'il est
vraiment fort parce que niall sarine les
gagnants depuis tout à l'heure
et honnêtement cette position là avec
cette seconde à la pendule elle n'est
pas si simple
ok c'est complètement gagnant si on est
en longue c'est complètement gagnant
mais là avec si peu de temps on va
regarder le reste la plus de quatre
secondes quand il se met à mal autant
d'entrées là c'est pas mal il veut il
veut à 4 d'un méchant il va se prendre
dame h5 d'amis sida met fin d'un match 5
le retour il peut pas refaire dame
détroit et il envoie à 4 da médecin qui
veut passer de l'autre côté mais il n'a
pas d'âme des uns parce que lecavalier
tient f 6 e 5 c'est logique il va faire
à 6
et là il a il arrête pas le plus en fait
s'il arrête avec le fou il met le fond à
8 à yap à damas huit échecs n'a pas
d'âme ses six hausses est terrible mais
il ya d'am-dam échecs dames b8 il va
prendre f3 roya du contre jeu là qu'elle
prend f2 cavaliers des trois-rois eu
deux cavaliers c'est un nom d'un cap bep
2 il va faire dame échec croix blandin
prendre trois noms il prend ici et ça
doit déjà il ya peut-être cavaliers
detroit qui est fort mais kate des trois
dames des 5
ouais c'est bouillant les gars dame f2
et l'ordi ladom dame point f3 comme
gagnant et cavaliers de d1
attendez les gars là c'est bouillant là
dès cette première partie moi il fait
cavaler détroit maintenant un échec
croit la dame mais il a dû calculé qu'il
y avait un match
est ce qu'il ya un matou pas moi je le
vois pas attendre les six amat cavaliers
f2i laisse les deux dames
alors là les gars alors là les gars il
faut les avoir bien accroché un d'un
machin qui a eu 80 et dame reprend aux
quatre os et bouillon de chez bouillant
quel début de match on est tous les
coups sont sont impressionnants là mais
ça va faire nul sûrement il ya dame
prend g7 maintenant ça redevient gagnant
pour les blancs il avait 3 5 forcé
quel parti il va faire d'annoncé de dame
prend b3 et roy f4 il se fait pas mater
ses shows de ses shows de night quelles
parties de dengue là pour commencer
match qui tient vraiment toutes ses
promesses 1 là j'ai envie de dire
personne c'est ce qui va se passer a
peut-être un roi f 4 1 qui a été ratée
mais je pense que ça va faire nul mais
une partie qui annonce le ton qui
annonce le tempo du match
quelle défense dyke quand même temps
allure combien de temps la partie déjà
on est déjà à 15,8 de jeu sur cette game
avec le roi qui est en train de rentrer
il est en train de se la gagner il va
faire dame b 3 way il est en train de se
la gagner
niall là il doit pas prendre le pion par
contre il doit vraiment pas prendre le
pion en irak qui est en train de la
gagner dame bessette seul coup
quelle défense ouais et dames 7 et c'est
gagné
qu'est ce que c'est bien joué de la part
de niall qui gagne la paire parti et ike
qui en a trop fait avec dame cavaliers
ils avaient des gains ils avaient des
gains mais mais il en a pas il n'en a
pas tiré profit avec les noirs mais
voilà moi je voyais les evaldo redit
dans l'ordi qui donne est complètement
gagnant pour les noirs mais honnêtement
honnêtement j'ai enfin voila je n'avais
pas vraiment le temps de voir les coûts
parce que ça ça à s'enchaîner mai mais
j'aurais pris là nul sans trop hésiter
un papa c'est en fait pour calculer les
deux dames qui donne des échecs ça fait
quand même peur en tout cas ça ça se
clôture par une victoire de niall qui
prend l'avantagé dans ce match et qui
mène maintenant 1 0
alors après voilà 1 010 sais rien mais
ça lui à être garé il ya encore
largement le temps de remonter côté
martirossian il reste encore trois
heures trente de jeu c'est pas fini j'ai
envie de dire c'est pas fini c'est
d'apprendre d'un prend cet hiver ab3
voir cette position là comment les value
c'est typique des gambie dame accepter
ou même des gants bidamant général avec
on a un pion de plus côté n'en a pas de
plus en plus on a la peur de foucauld
thé blanc on a un pion de plus sur l'ale
dame pour les noirs est un pion de plus
sur les droits pour les blancs donc ces
majorités au centre compte majorité
allèles dame s'est pas forcément mieux
pour l'un venu pour l'autre ça joue
plutôt à l'activité des pièces perso je
prendrai les blancs dans cette position
sans trop hésiter mais l'ordinateur d'un
avantage noir
t les parties de séries comme ça parce
que finalement n'est pas bien sûr de qui
est plus fort je suis 100% d'accord avec
toi jéjé nu et jenny génie pgc parties
devraient être devrait être déclarée
nulle par l' arbitre mais c'est vrai
après que le problème c'est que des
parties serrées comme ça en début de
match c'est tellement diluées dans
énormément de game qui vont qui vont
arriver devant il ya tellement de partis
à venir il va y avoir 20 25 parties dans
le match et c'est vrai que du coup le
fait que le match soit aussi long ça
fait perdre énormément d'intérêt même
assez partie serrée qui sont tellement
diluées dans autre chose
le point était attribuée à ok donc ok il
faut que je change le match et a annoncé
comme martirossian compte niall ils se
sont trompés de l'autre côté du coup je
dois changer merci merci et néron c'est
une erreur de l'équipe design qui a mis
le truc à l'envers auparavant du coup on
l'a remis à l'endroit
alors cette position maintenant elle est
un peu mieux pour les noirs à cause du
fait qu'ils aient pas fou b2 à cause de
tour dès 2011 dans la même position avec
le foin des de la tour en d1
ça y est c'est pas si grave contre une
majorité elle dame d'avoir à quatre c4
isolé
mais à l'autre
c'est quoi iman qui manque beaucoup de
placement qu'avantage génial j'aime pas
trop ce début de match les gars qui sent
le système de 7,2 partie par cadence ça
suffirait on pourrait faire disons 4
parties de 5-plus ainsi partie de trois
plus un et moi je mettrais que deux
parties de bullet à la fin si jamais il
ya égalité en fait
mais si on veut mettre du bullet on
pourrait mettre quatre parties de belote
à la fin ce qui ferait un match
2 à peu près une heure une heure
quarante-cinq quelque chose comme ça ce
serait quand même à mon avis beaucoup
plus intéressant pour les spectateurs
est beaucoup plus agréable à jouer pour
les joueurs mais il y aura un peu moins
de pages de publicité pendant le match
après pas ça le plus important mais bon
on a ces formats très très long c'est
comme ça mais c'est vrai que même même
les partis un peu chaud du coup c'est
difficile de s'emballer parce qu'il
reste il reste tellement à venir que la
partie est loin d'être décisif pour quoi
que ce soit à quoi tient au moment où
c'est décisif c'est le moment le moins
intéressant c'est le bullet en fait où
les partis ont beaucoup plus de valeur
du coup quand c'est quand les matches
sont serrés mais à
mais bon j'espère quand même avoir des
trucs qui sont construits plus de a à z
ou alors faut il commencer par les
bulles est à la rigueur tient cavalière
5 c'est pas mal il revisite élégamment
la casse des quatre ça c'est un très bon
coup de la part de de niall s'efforçant
c'est mieux les noirs ont là que la
seule colonne ouverte de l'échiquier et
ils ont le cavalier des quatre qui est
bien mais mon faut voir que les blancs à
tout moment pourrait prendre en d4
normalement c'est le genre de truc avec
les blancs tu dis je vais souffrir mais
je vais la tenir
et je
vous avez lu j'ai réussi à trouver
finalement la conférence de presse de
tigran petrosyan entièrement traduite
apparemment il connaît même pas lui
l'épreuve est apparemment les parties
dans lesquelles ils seraient incriminés
sont plutôt les parties des demi-finales
plus que celle de la finale donc on
continue dans la grande bizarrerie
puisqu'il ya quand même eu eux 48 heures
entre les deux matches il est sur reddit
koudil of quid il a peut-être quelqu'un
va être le maître dans le tchat
après son excuse pour regarder vers le
bas c'est que il joue autres à hauteur
du pad
ce qui est bien étonnant
mais après oui d'après d'après ce qu'ils
disent et qu'il lui a dit qu'il avait
qui avait un problème en demi finale et
non pas en finale après j'en sais rien
honnêtement
tours s'est dit prêt par f5 s'il a
incriminé pour la demie du coup les bras
demande à être qualifié en finale va du
coup c'est comme il a incriminé
apparemment pour la demie max déjà lu il
dit pourquoi on nous a laissés jouer y
avait quand même 48 heures quoi donc du
coup lui il utilise ça comme argument
pour dire que c'est parce que c'est
wesley so qui a violé qui a eu quelque
chose ou pas ce que c'est les américains
qui n'ont pas gagné mais je trouve son
argument assez juste tapé trop sur un
pour vous dire la vérité après on va on
va repasser des heures encore à parler
de ça ça m'embête un peu mais c'est vrai
que là tu as martirossian qui jouent en
demi-finale enfin bon soit il ya aucune
cohérence de rien là c'est les tournois
sont complètement incohérent tu as des
gars qui sont incriminés pour des
matches en demi
tu as des gars de l'équipe qui doivent
être ses complices forcément parce que
là quand à trois joueurs sur les quatre
titulaires dans l'équipe c'est quand
même un petit peu spécial
enfin bon ça fait 1
ça fait un amalgame de choses qui font
très très mal aux événements là ah oui
tu l'incriminent pour la demie est
obligé de refaire jouer la finale à la
théorie j'ai je suis on est on est 100 %
d'accord avec maxime si tu dis qu'il ya
eu problème
en demies du coup la finale est caduc et
tu dois toujours faire jouer tu peux pas
dire saint-louis vainqueur du coup c'est
pas possible
donc il ya beaucoup d'incohérences et
quid de martirossian qui joue maintenant
maximin parce que comme je disais effet
assez facile d'y arriver trois joueurs
sur quatre dans l'équipe machin et tout
mais il dit aussi qu'on lui a demandé
qu'on lui a demandé un truc assez
marrant ils disent que pour étouffer la
faire ils lui ont proposé de qu'il
accepte de
de dire qu'il avait triché et que du
coup il aurait étouffé l'affairé il
aurait continué à l'autoriser à jouer
sur czech comme s'il avait accès accepté
de plaider coupable
donc ils réussissent à dans les trucs un
peu intéressants
là encore c'est un petit peu bizarre tu
plaide coupable et puis du coup on
change tout juste deux vainqueurs il n'y
a pas de problème ce qui je sais
arrivait pas mal de fois pour la peine
mais il a vraiment dit qu'il regardait
un match qui joue au touch adore sais
c'est pas lui qui l'a dit ces attaques
qu'il a dit il a vraiment dit qu'il
regardait vers le bas parce qu'ils
jouent au touchpad sio honnêtement est
un peu fort de café quoi
ils ont demandé de plaider coupable oui
c'est ce qu'ils ont c'est ce qui c'est
ce qu'il a dit afin de ne pas rendre la
faire vraiment public et juge changer le
vainqueur suite à des erreurs de
fair-play paraît pas aller plus loin
quoi d'après ce qu'ils disent et les
dires de petrossian après un que que je
vous communique un jeu ne connaît en
aucun cas la véracité des propos ses
fans c'est lui qui disent à quoi me anna
par andré son bureau m il fout plein de
papiers dedans et salue la boulette
mons est parti avec comme ça reste un
peu mieux pour les noix pour le moment
ça tournicote
arnaud eto'o il ya eu triche moi je
dirais une présomption de triche un mois
j'ai quand même envie de donner la
présomption d'innocence à petrossian
perso parce que de façon ça à partir en
procès cette histoire
qu'à lui il y là il a clairement dit que
ça allait partir en procès il le dit
clairement dans le dans la dans la
conférence de presse il dit clairement
qui va qui va réunir tous les éléments
et là il envoie le petit duo de pions
maintenant et va envoyer à tour un f6 il
fait pas tourner il est à me prend 2,3
alors ça c'est étonnant quand même ah
oui il n'a pas vu juste oui oui c'est
étonnant de de laisser dame prend 1,3 on
a vu à la caméra qui faisait un petit
haussement de tête
c'est spectaculaire dont trois
spectaculaires
je pense m
mais commence à partir des quarts en
tout cas martirossian qui est pas dans
son match pour le moment enfin prévoir
et toute une discussion sur reddit que
vous pouvez lire la plupart des gens
pensent à peu près comme nous j'ai envie
de dire de ce que je vois les légendes
plutôt modéré on va dire ils sont un peu
dans ce qu'on dit que les locaux à son
petit ouest indienne en voilà s'ajouter
aux rites pour le moment
donc les résultats étaient plus que
suspect y est donc
et donc il y avait neuf et des
suspicions qui était clair mais qu'après
l'épreuve pour le monde sont pas fans
très très très impressionnante
niane pas apathique comme encas royan
car il était vraiment pas dans pas long
le pas dans le mien rail qui fait un
mauvais début de match alors la première
partie pouvait prendre là nul
il ne l'a pas fait
maxime julie en vrai d'ailleurs la
disparition de 300 qu'il ait triché ou
non n'auriez rien dû changer au fait que
ça aurait dû être suspendu aussi ah oui
so so so aurait dû prendre un père m'a
ban ah oui à 200 % d'heures si la fidh
était un petit peu cohérente accusations
de triche sans preuves comme ça aussi
véhémente normalement c'est perds ma
balle
normalement c'est perma ban quoi qu'il
en soit normalement ça aurait dû aller
au père m'a ban c'est vrai aussi maxime
serait que dans tous les cas tu aurais
pas dû avoir à l'affronter ce soir au
caire fou projet de et rock
la fidh n'a rien à voir
ban dans un sens si parce que en tout
cas déjà deux chaises comme on aurait dû
le faire et
en tout cas pas perma ban n'a en tous
cas à lui mettre un avertissement mais
pour la fidh si c'est quand même calme
accusations d'un autre joueur adhérents
de la fidh pour triche à leur règlement
de la paix salsa j'ai pas vu maxime les
accusations publiques ça gg j'ai pas
suivi alors c'est à cette affaire la
fidh aurait pu au pur au moins pu faire
une petite remontrance quand même façon
que c'est un peu le monde à l'envers où
tout le monde le p pourquoi tout le
monde paie ponsot en mode à bravo socoa
alors que dans les règlements y va à
l'encontre de tout c'est plus ça après
whip herman gens rêvent toujours un
petit peu c'est un peu dur mais au moins
au moins un avertissement assorti d'une
petite suspension peut-être même juste
symbolique peut-être même peut-être même
une semaine voilà juste comme ça
certaines équipes qui ne connaît pas le
règlement mais bon on n'accuse personne
de tricher aussi nous ont dit que ses
adversaires sont très très fort mais
quand même plus malin que lui quoi nous
on le sait depuis des années mais on dit
juste qu'on est sûr qu'ils vont gagner
qui sont très très fort nous on part du
principe que on à l'elysée
résultats des équipes à la wii est très
très fort il joue à 2852 1900 ils sont
très forts on est très heureux de ce à
quoi vous jouez très très bien c'est
génial bravo quoi
non mais la base c'est au moins
d'émettre des doutes de toute façon mais
pas d'être peut-être aussi direct et à
et aussi sur salue m yogourt vlad spirit
métier mais kiev 7 bon les blancs sont
nous vaut mieux un fonds voit bien il ya
trois îlots de haut contre deux et il
veut faire tourner un tour heureux et
sans prendre et s'en prendre au centre
donc là il ya de nouveau un problème
pour les blancs bike qui n'est pas du
tout rentrer dans le match et on match
mc du coup ça à 21h le tien où il est
fou jouer tous s'en séparer j'ai pas
réussi à trouver l'info j'avoue j'avoue
j'ai pas réussi à trouver l'info
je pense toujours en même temps ok pas
possible c'est ce que j'ai pensé mais
après comme d'habitude dans les title
tune et ils jouent pas tout en même
temps je me suis peut-être ils jouent
pas tout en même temps quoi après je me
demandais comment comment il ferait
aussi un jeu te cache pas et c'est en
six parties kaun ans max ça je les lui
mais je me rappelle plus déjà c'est un
bo 6 non ça reste dur pour ike qui m'a
l'air vraiment dans le mal dans ce match
après on n'est à l'abri de rien brise h
à ses onze partis assez pas bo 6 c'est
le premier à 6 ok ok donc j'ai mal lu
ouais mais ça va être très long ça va
être très très long parce que ces
huitièmes de finale comme ça quarts de
finale demi-finale finales hommes et
c'est parti pour des heures
voilà quelle catastrophe à mais au moins
on va être bien sûr que ça veut dire
qu'il va y avoir un gros 44 parties de
trois plus un c3 + 1 ce soir dans 5 + 1
x 2 3 + 1 x 2 1 + 1 x 6 ok oui tu m'a
écrit ça oui mais voilà j'ai compris
alors mais j'ai rien compris je suis
complètement mélanger j'ai dû lire avec
un format d'un autre truc tu vas tu as
lu un truc de cette année ah oui non
mais ça va être terrible avec une heure
de pause entre chaque match
non mais
du suicide en fait alors attends c'est à
dire qu'un match c'est à dire quoi ça
dure 20 minutes on va lire 35 aucun
match dure 50 minutes on va dire en gros
un nom ça c'était une blague afld en
grand-am à 10h50
bon il va bien avoir un quart d'heure de
pause donc ses 58 par match et a quatre
matches on va dire ça à faire 1h10
ouais ça va durer cinq heures en gros
comment 1h15 le match ouais nathan 5 + 1
on va dire ça fait vingt-cinq minutes 3
+ 1 on va dire ça fait 17 minutes ça
fait 42 43 1 + 1 on va dire ça fait une
heure
non mais c'est de la folie pure à trois
plus un tas dit qu'il y avait deux
parties ou c'est moi qui lis mal ça fait
six fois de 12 plus le rajout à loin ce
qu'ils en aient quatre études soient
plantés parce que si ces deux 2,6 ça va
assez foix iii paris iii bat a fait 5 +
1 x 2 3 + 1 x 2' + 1 x 6 je peux te je
peux te mettre le copier copier coller
oui donc j'ai dit oui donc c'est une
heure dix puisque j'étais à une heure
avec avec x 2 donc si c'est x 3 ces dix
minutes de plus et c'est une heure dix
souhaitent donc c'est une heure dix ans
par match on va dire que les matchs
commencent après 1h30
non c'est pas grave on attend pas à
t'excuser max c'est juste un mix clic
prenons qu'un 4 à t'excuser mais à
mais du coup du coup ça fait ouais ça à
faire 1h30 1h30
x 2 x 3 et la finale j'imagine que le
format est plus lisse et 7h on est
d'accord
donc là une bonne nul pour pour ike on
est d'accord c'est cette oeuvre est donc
ça va faire 21h 4h du mat
non mais c'est terrible c'est terrible
ah oui non mais ça va être terrifiant
c'est exceptionnel c'est exceptionnel et
du coup c'est pour ça qu'ils ont mis le
match avant je stream tout et web it
fait vite fait non mais on va attendre
tant qu' un max de dans wii mais après
suivant non surtout qu'ils ont dit un
truc sans dire ouais on déplace le
speech est junior pour pour que ça soit
pour pouvoir bien tout ce trimestre et
ils m'ont envoyé ça mais en fait les
mecs en gros ce qui m'ont demandé c'est
de stream et de 17 heures à 4 heures du
matin là en fait je suis en train de
réaliser
c'est qu'en fait ils ont juste demandé
de streaming non-stop de 17 heures à 4
heures du mat ce qui te fait quand même
11h02 stream non-stop ah oui non mais
oui c'est c'est très gentil quoi pour
bien-être sur quoi pour le ché pa énième
dimanches d'affilée et qua non mais
c'est terrible tf qui découvrent la
double on dirait que oui oui non mais le
stream ne va pas durer jusqu'à quatre
heures du matin à moins ce qui est
maxime annoncé à maxime on va soutenir
maxime à fond on va lutter contre le
sommeil ensemble on va être très très
chaud ça c'est autre chose maxime va au
bout on sera là à 5 heures du mat si le
forain you will never walk alone là là
là y'a pas y'a pas y'a pas y'a pas y'a
pas
à réfléchir non de toute façon je ça
serait très vite qu'on va streamé on va
se créer sur bitstream tranquillement
puis au moins on fera autre chose
pendant c'est une grosse pause j'ai
prévu qu'on fasse un championnat du
monde de cyclisme
je me suis un peu entraîné hier pour
essayer d'envoyer on essaye d'envoyer à
l'afp
champion du monde pendant une pause pour
alors cette position du coup on ne va
pas trop parler c'est une structure
carlsbad en gros il ya quand même ce
pion à cinq équidés de fer b4 kaïs et 5
par habitude sur est content de la joue
avec les blancs mais je serais content
de la jouer avec les noirs aussi fort ça
va ça va pour tout le monde
mollard doit pas tomber non mais je me
suis entraîné ya gg la strate mais il
faut qu'on ait les bonnes notes mais
j'ai la strate en fait la strate en fait
pour gagner le championnat du monde avec
à la fin elle est très très simple j'ai
pas gagné hier mais je j'ai compris la
strata faire il va y avoir aucun
problème
donc oui on suivra ça et puis tant que
maxime skalli filles on suivra et puis
en espérant que les maxis les matches se
jouent en même temps pardon parce que
sinon si les demi finales il décide de
les jouer décalé et que ça fini à 6
heures du mat non donc ok on c'est ça le
truc c'est avec les noirs tu à gammarth
où le jeu sur la taxe sur le roi
après ma théorie de maxime sont relevées
bras de dallas philippe c'est qu'en
réalité il sait qu'il n'a pas gagné la
course pour moi en fait une fois qu il
le fait il sait qu'il a fait une énorme
erreur une énorme bêtise et il sait que
il sait qu'il va être déclassé pour moi
vous disqualifier et donc il lève les
bras comme ça par par inertie ou je sais
pas comment appeler ça en fait sauf à
être inertie le mot mais off je sais pas
il a un mélange dans sa tête et il fait
ça mais mais il sait que c'est perdu
voilà l'idée des blancs normand cdc joué
4 quand même parce que sinon ça peut
arriver vite sur le roi donc ce qui
commence par un dam des deux prélève les
bras mais je sais pas il est peut-être
dégoûté qu'il est disqualifié il ya
plein de choses qui se passent dans sa
tête en nous rendant en même temps il
lève les bras je pense c'est ce que j'ai
pensé immédiatement quand il a fait en
fait ce que j'ai tout de suite pensé
qu'il était disqualifié et dès qu'il a
levé les bras giauque et justice j'ai
pas un mélange d'émotions dans sa tête
et il l'a fait je dis pas que ça fait
sens 1 mégi jusqu en fait c'est le genre
de moment où en l'espace d'une demi
seconde
tu as plein de choses qui vont dans la
tête tu fais un truc incohérents en fait
mais je pense que c'est lié à ça
je peux peut-être pour influencer les
arbitres j'en sais rien moi tu ta ta ta
peut-être des idées idiotes comme ça
qu'ils deviennent à la tête
bon qui prépare 4-1 tour 2 c'est l'idée
de faire tout re 4 mois j'ai proposé dam
des deux mais je préfère tour de toi
parce que au moins s'activent la torah
c'est la même chose mais en mieux en
fait cyril façon il ne le vois pas
gagner le tour de france
ouais mais après en fait le tour de
france c'est hyper important que pour
pour que pour les gens cycliques ce qui
suivent que le tour de france
en réalité le tour de france c'est pas
c'est pas une fin en soi
wen ya la meilleure mine je crois que ça
al'avantage vraiment là d'où une heure
plus tôt je pense que c'est ça il doit
il doit se coucher vers il ya deux
heures et demi d'écart il doit se
coucher habituellement vers 21h30 22h il
nous fait une cornetto quoi il a il a la
tête qui plonge à partir d'une certaine
heure donc prise je mets une qui prend 2
h mais il va préparer
il va essayer de préparer aux 4 après ça
commence à échanger en c5 qu'on va être
ai je pense qu'il prend tous enfin il
prend tout de suite en tout cas je pense
après son petit défaut avec le tour eux
deux le seul petit défaut c'est que tu
as pu roigé deux tours h1 qui aurait été
sympa pour pour combler la colonne h
ouais faut prendre qu'à trois rois j'ai
deux dames 2 et tourache un bon remède
le truc tour de france maxime pour moi
c'est un peu le débat toute façon tu
peux pas tout gagné au cyclisme tatata
trop de courses avec un profil différent
et en gros en terme d'importance c'est
peut-être le tour c'est le plus grand
tour pour les coureurs de tours sert
cité coire de tours giro vuelta et tour
de france tu te base tu te bases sur le
tour de france mais c'est pas moins bien
d'être noir classique en fête est pour
moi le coup les coureurs les moins
importants entre guillemets c'est les
sprinteurs faites moi j'ai une
classification j'aurais plus les plus
forts que moi c'est les baroudeurs
puncheur genre les hirschi alaphilippe
et compagnie après tu as les couloirs de
full full haute montagne seulement mais
maintenant ils sont plus ils sont plus
plus hybride ce que tu as même roglit
qui gagne aujourd'hui au gatt chars dont
quand vous faites ce tu fais les deux
c'est encore mieux su peut gagner les
grands tours et les classiques c'est
encore mieux
mais genre on va dire qu'on a les
classiques c'est un peu au dessus avec
les grands tours encore que à discuter
après les sprinteurs qui sont quand même
pour moi en dessous mais pour moi les
baroudeurs puncheur genre à l'afld qui
gagne les championnats du monde les
milan san remo les lez liège bastogne
liège les paris roubaix tout ça c
et c'est hyper important pour argument
tour bien au dessus je suis pas d'accord
mais bon en tout cas en point us et
c'est souvent les baroudeurs puncheur tu
finisses devant et je trouve que c'est
plus difficile comme effort parce qu'en
fait ils se préparent ils sont est bon
sur les grands tours ce qu'ils vont
prendre des grosses d'étape est bon tout
au long de la saison mais plus puncheur
que baroudeur ouais ouais ouais ouais ok
on est d'accord
bon voilà ce qu'est en train de faire ce
qu en train de faire notre ami sarine
c'est hyper dangereux puisqu'ils
ramènent le fou sur la taxe qui va
ramener les tours et le cavalier peut
être un peu en jeu dangereux sauf que il
ya un sauf et il ya un mais c'est qu'on
n'a pas tous rage suite directe à cause
de cavaliers ou six donc le cavalier
tient temporairement la baraque et peut
avoir des cavaliers 17 cavaliers 5
rebonds
les corps de gros temps sont plus connus
du grand public mais à mais tu vois un
jalabert a été numéro 1 mondial sur
plusieurs saisons alors qu'il a qui
s'était pas un coureur de grand tour
donc tu as me de trois charges
confirmant ce que veulent faire les
blancs les blancs ils veulent faire nul
la ssq il joue avec tour h2k il n'a pas
le temps de tout âge de tout rachat
roigé un comme ça ils auraient pu
protéger à attaquer
ce qui fait tout rage de roy g1 ou est
ce qu'il défend avec tours f1 il lui
manque un tempo en fait non
4 jalabert il a gagné une vuelta mais en
gros le plus gros de sa carrière c'était
sprinteurs au début puis après pouvoir
coureur de classiques il a gagné le giro
il n'a pas gagné le tour de france où il
a gagné la vuelta pas le tour de france
où le giro qui sont plus durs mais quand
même oui un principe pour rim écoutons à
fond pour haïti là il peut peut-être
faire un dame g4 pour toucher du
cavalier ou six comme ça il pousse
peut-être fou prend ses 5 il a plus de
problème faut faire gaffe côté sarine je
pense d'un air froid c'est bien joué
puisque la partie aurait pu tourner et
là la question c'est ce que les blancs
peuvent essayer de la de la gent retour
age 2 3g un tour b un tour b2 mais c'est
un peu longuet il prend en f3 alors ils
espèrent eux f10 hk 3g quatre là c'est
ça ce serait parfait et belle à ces
grosses fautes
même moi j'ai vu ces terribles
d'ailleurs sarine vient de le comprendre
aussi
et là maintenant je pensais qu'il allait
essayer d'allier la torah suite
peut-être tour f 5 tours h 8 et tours et
sète tours g8 à tour h6 bien jouer ouais
ouais ça c'est royal
attention j'ai quatre sacs marche
peut-être pas il a fait quatre prises
prise sur wager 4,3 à gagner sur gk3 f4
ça gagne hélas roi ou trois sous deux
angles et roy le 4 mai la f4
tranquille on fait le pion passé et on
gagne la finale a aimé e pro f 3 c'était
moche un énorme l'erreur de sa une mais
moi je les ai vus à l'avant ce problème
trois rois je crois j'ai quatre sa part
et c'est gravissime donc fort en finale
avec ice est un bon joueur un maxime qui
l'a souvent qu'il a souvent joué que
c'est un joueur assez complet
kia qui a vraiment toutes les qualités
des du blitz heures en fait c'est à dire
bien dans le petit jeu tactique bien
dans les finales est assez solide d'un
point de vue général c'est c'est un
joueur vraiment taillé pour le blitz
mais oui qui est qui est assez bon en
dans le petit jeu tactique et et les
finales ouais on va avoir la 5
évidemment l'idée c'est de se sécuriser
la casse b4 pour le cavalier qui est une
belle case laquelle 17 c'est pour
chasser le cavalier e 5 samsung était
doublé jusqu'à la moelle et pâques à la
moelle il était fait pas que et pas que
parler sans valse ben là tu reprends de
quoi il réfléchit d'ailleurs est ce que
tu en prends pas du fou ce que foutent
face à lloris faire chasser par quatre
aurait pu le mettre en justice mais tu
peut-être reprendre du fou et partir sur
un g6 fou g7 après rock et jouer avec
eux 5 où ces cinq cas là il a pris de la
dame à la halle à grünfeld
alors maintenant serre qui doit jouer
avec le set up avec le 6 mai ya
peut-être un problème avec ce cavalier
qui est très mal placé maintenant
en fait ce cavalier il était bien si on
faisait ça et ça et qu'on va mener le
cavalier en b 4 là il était cool le
problème c'est que
il n'a pas le temps de faille peut pas
le faire et donc le cavalier il serait
mieux place en 17 maintenant donc
peut-être d'amd 8 et un coup bon là faut
regarder des cinq des 5 et le coup
thématique tutu doit pas laisser les
noirs sont organisées ici
un cavalier ses 8
ouais c'est pas une belle position pour
les noirs une nouvelle fois mais c'est
pas catane ont plus à rien de moins et
il veut fouet cette rock
après ça soit un qui est un problème
bien quoi me fous ces quatre mêmes peut
être pénible peut-être amiens caïds et 6
rebonds
le truc c'est que sur puis on prend un
but on prend peut prendre de la dame le
pion précise quand même d'un prend 1,6
et en dames des quatre peut-être pour
essayer de faire pousser 4 mai à
peut-être qu'à celui ci soit ces genres
de position évidemment les blancs doit
être mieux il a fait pris ces six dames
d1 il va reprendre et baisser non mais
c'est sûr que les blancs sont un peu
mieux mais il va faire flamber quatre
cavaliers set rock et tour des huit ça
va ça ça ça se tient encore
rang de la course paraît quand même le
plus logique hein il va faire dépenser 6
mai tête s'il réfléchit au coup d'après
déjà ce pas une mauvaise technique parce
que du coup il est l'incertitude sur cac
et prend des impasses que lui de façon
il est sûr qu'il y aura b prend ses six
au prochain il a pris du roi a pour mac
laurence et 2 je pensais qu'il allait
prendre de la tour faire football-roi
ces deux tours des deux tours d un et il
veut faire le plan avec tours d un tour
c'est un qui est pas idiot mais il perd
un peu de il perd un peu de jus dans sa
position il va faire si swatch cinq
façons ils obligeaient jarre manche
plutôt partisan de h5 quand vous tempo
mais si ça peut être pas mal même si ça
laisse de l'expansion et il doit vouloir
jouer avec f5 du coup h si c'est ça se
marie avec f5 donc là le plan des danses
et un truc le roi aux 7 qui est des six
tours des huit f5 genre le plan
principal 1 après il peut y avoir
d'autres idées et je me plante
complètement il fait cavalier e set pour
menacer cavaliers des cinq pour essayer
d'échanger des pièces et profiter du
clouage du pion aux 4 c'est loin d'être
idiot
ce que fouleront enfin il faut c'est
dangereux voilà c'est très concret un le
truc c'est que c'est difficile de là les
joueurs jouent concret évidemment on
recommande jamais de mettre un roi en
face du fou mais à quai les joueurs sont
plus qu'un sens où c'est ce sens là ça
jouait là ça joue très concret même si
de base j'aime moi j'aurais plutôt mis
leur ont eu deux persos en me disant que
le fou été bloqués ici et que et que
j'allais mettre mes tours comme ça ça me
paraissait plus logique mais après ses
joueurs toujours mieux que moi et donc
s'il fait ça c'est qu'il a calculé des
choses là c'est du concret après paris
ce qui fait qu'il y ait des cinq quand
même fou des 4es marche pas si j'allais
kapsys pour vous je pense qu'il va jouer
avec six pour des fondements donc il n'a
pas fait fou des quatre il fait preuve
de aya pas f5 ce qui a pu on prend des
cinqs dommage kf5 acquis des 4 et
cavaliers trois ce serait fort donc fait
fou aux 7 et il redonne la case f4 pour
le cavalier bon sache cinq fois je sais
tu sais tu es du sûr il va sûrement
jouer avec petit rock en réalité parce
que sinon c'est si fait fois çi ce 3e
set aura poussé 5 et grand roque voyais
quoique ci peut faire grand rocroi
bessette pour à l'école maternelle dame
ça peut être aussi une idée si a pas de
tactique à base d'oeuf ou les six gros
rock peut être une idée aussi si y'a pas
de problème tactique 1 je me répète et
ça peut ne pas être idiot d'ailleurs
parce que le roi en b 7 sera pas mal
placé 1
il va protéger là il va courir un peu ça
en tout cas des fous ici il fait petit
rock le coup le premier convoi qui était
des problèmes de foie en russie un tas
d'effets ou un fou prend donc il fait
fou des trois îles
temps de mettre un tour en b 8 bon là il
fallait bouger le cavalier évidemment
parce qu'il y avait le clouage qui
étaient partis mais mais il va être
temps de mettre cette tour en b 8 je
pense essayer de naviguer avec du
cavalier de 17 cavaliers c5
il va faire tourner fb 8 il va peut-être
je sais pas quelle pièce on en met 4 mai
la torah bon il doit considérer que son
pion peut pas être attaquée et que cette
tour peut être utile autrement
moi je voyais ça comme ça dans le sens
où les garder la protection 2 à 5
c'est pas dit que ce soit pas plus fort
comme il le fait et ici cavaliers de 17
way avec éventuellement sur grande foi
si je voulais faire roi c'est cette en
fait bêtement mais il se peut que j'aie
raté une tactique un genre à base de
foie si c'est à foix avec l'idée de
gagner à 5
donc le fou qui repart là ils provoquent
cavaliers c5 est fou c'est 4 je vous
annonce que c'est beaucoup moins clair
que tout à l'heure un tour b cette
tourbe et 8,3 f8 fou g8 f5 ça peut être
une manière de continuer wave 5 avant
même sans faire flouer 8 alors why fuite
c'est pour éviter de se prendre un fou
prend aussi sur échec
là il va faire tour fb huit tours b1
j'imagine est roi et fuite
peut-être pour jouer avec f5
après je suis peut-être un peu
monomaniaque de f 5 1 mais en tout cas
la position qu'ils s'améliorent et niall
star inc à plus de 17 secondes à lake
qui revient dans le match a très
clairement
alors il n'a pas joué tourbains il a il
a décidé finalement de donner son fou et
c'est vrai qu'il manque un tempo pour
avoir le 5-fu des 4 je sais c'est normal
aux échecs
c'était un peu calculé pour même
peut-être à faire broyer fuite et qui
déçus retour des 8 3e set et le roi
vient colmater la colonne des et suroît
et fuite tour des sept îles à roye 8
il fait fausse est d'accord sur tours 17
farewell fuite c'est sûr et sur fois ci
si la tour prend b3 donc il va échanger
il va mettre le fou ici alors maintenant
aux cinq à six fours g8 et un plan
pour venir taper sur le pion aux baies 3
ça je l'appris une vieille partie de
bronstein jolie partie de bronstein où
il avait fait un une manoeuvre comme ça
il était moins bien il avait renversé la
partie avec 7 avec ce plan depuis c'est
un plan que j'aime bien faire il a fait
g5
j'aurais jamais pensé à ce coup mais il
est peut-être très fort mais il se prend
au 50 km et qui vont jamais exactement
oui offert h 5 h 4 alors là le truc
c'est que c'est que tu essayes de la
gagner avec les noirs tu étais mal toute
la partie là y'a pas fou prend ses six
parce que tu était cloué et ton
adversaire a plus de temps et a décidé
comme bref saint-croix g4 là pour entrer
qui est décisif où prend des six puis on
prend des six tours 17
il va faire 1 5
mais l'ordinateur dit que c'est gagnant
après roy c4 qui on prend pions prend
est roi c'est 5 à ces terribles assez
terrible leroy f 5 tiger
pour yves s'inquiéter une gaffe les amis
j'aurais fait exactement la même erreur
je vous ai proposé le coup c'est pour
dire à quel point j'aurais fait la faute
donc là la seule chance apparemment
c'est de faire le k3 ses 5 3 o6 f5
essayé d'envoyer le pion pour récupérer
des six c'est terrible à l'erreur qu'il
a fait avec
je n'aurais pas fait mieux l'haïtien
qu'il a déconné dès que tu vois roja c4
a compris que c'était fini
kiffer h4 il va reprendre en f4 anaïs et
là c'est sûr que c'est fini grosse
enfin très grosse gaffe allez il tente
quand même le truc d'envoyer les pions
ouais mais il force 3 h si c'est bien
joué ça est maintenant sûr aux deux
tours e1 et suroît g5 h6 très bien joué
de la part de niall ouais c'était bien
joué le tour h un tour f1 au tempo près
3 ea continue
voilà il va abandonner après h6 parce
que la f3 et d'amont premier f2 il ya
juste n'importe quel échec ça gagne bien
joué bien mieux de la part de niall et
ike qui finalement le plan naturel la 2e
5 et 6 qui étaient peut-être pas le
meilleur
d'ailleurs je vous dis à ossun kapsys
mais c'est parce que c'est ça me
paraissait logique hein c'était pas
forcément le plus fort et c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'il fait pas le il fait pas
ce plan il va peut-être faire un truc
qui était meilleure mais qui laissait
plus de jeu finalement aux blancs tout
est meilleur parce que ces coûts étaient
bien bien bien évalué par l'ordi mais je
sais pas sa santé le truc qui pouvaient
qui pouvait mal tourner il s'est un peu
grisé en fait il était tellement mal
tout le long qui s'est un petit peu
grise et miri la cache pas qu'il a 16
ans n'ira ligne al manar le signal
sarine
née en 2004 il a 16 ans solide 1 ike qui
lui pose moins de problème finalement
haye que qui lui pose moins de problème
que que son adversaire du tour précédent
antoine smirnov qu'il a posé tous les
poulets plus tôt et plus grands
problèmes du monde et finalement le sens
en difficulté alors que là dans ce match
me semble très bien dans le sens bien
dedans
bon là il est ce juke au piano avec le
fou qui est repassée via en f4
d'annoncer un excellent joueur niall
après on verra on sait on sait que la
plupart de ses joueurs un nuage que je
connais pas la la la situation
personnelle de niall sarine mais on sait
que que beaucoup de ces joueurs indiens
sont déscolarisés qu'au fond qui fonçait
twitter d'échec par jour et le truc
c'est qu'ils peuvent peut-être atteindre
leur plafond de verre beaucoup plus plus
jeune que que les que ce que les jeunes
qui jusqu'à maintenant avait des
déviants va dire entre guillemets plus
classique
donc le fait qu'ils arrivent très jeune
très fort
c'est assez impressionnant d'un autre
côté est ce que finalement en faisant en
faisant 4 5 heures des chèques par jour
de plus que les autres il n'arrive pas
plus vite au niveau qui devrait
atteindre à 22 23 ans et donc au moment
où on peut arriver à son niveau max un
petit peu bloquée c'est une question
qu'on peut se poser puisque c'est avec
ces joueurs indiens pour le monde en a
beaucoup qui ont beaucoup de jeunes là
qui ont qui sont bien montés mais on n'a
pas encore un de ces jeunes cracks là
qui est monté au dessus de 2007 donc à
voir ce que ça donne à voir
ça donne est-ce que ça ça va pas ça pas
bloquée un moment un peu un peu plus bas
ce que leur courbe de progression du
coup elle est un peu plus elle va un peu
plus vite vers l'eau et puis après il
stagne un peu plus on verra on sais pas
en tout cas on ne sait pas est-ce que
j'ai cinq une idée si oui clairement
séraphine roja est passé aux 2700 qu'au
début de cette année on les laisse
arrivé je suis fatigué c'est pareil mais
cyril juste on sait pas c'est des
générations de joueurs qui ont un
entraînement complètement différent des
générations précédentes
donc du coup faudra qu'on juge aussi la
leur progression sur le long terme
avec la lyre et sao tomé on verra on
verra quand ils arriveront au top il a
quel âge alireza actuellement il a 17
ans il a k'un non plus un ali reza il
avait montré des résultats quand même
supérieur aux jeunes indiens
après comme je vous dis on verra on
verra ce qu'il en est en temps voulu
alireza il en est où
ces routes déjà 2728 way et il a un an
de plus mais bon après il ya six mois là
où ça a pas joué du tout aussi ça rentre
en compte
après sa rencontre pour les deux
pierre bodein on ne voit plus trop mais
j'ai l'impression qu'il a changé un
petit peu son entraînement savait que
beaucoup joué sur internet savez
peut-être ses limites et il doit il doit
très clairement il doit très clairement
changer changer sa méthode de jeu s'il
veut arriver au plus haut niveau en
partie longue donc il doit probablement
changer sa méthode d'entraînement et je
pense que c'est une très bonne chose
pour lui qu'on voit moins sur internet
et qui performent moins en blitz sur
internet je pensais c'est une très bonne
chose pour eux
pour mieux performer justement en partie
longue réel après
après on verra on verra bien ce que ça
donne c'est comme voilà comme on sait on
sait pas on savap on sait pas où ça va
l'amener monter au très très haut niveau
c'est quand même quelque chose qui est
pas qui est pas offert à tous et il ya
beaucoup de joueurs qui peuvent plafonné
à 27 37 47 50
c'est vraiment difficile de rentrer dans
ce cercle des joueurs aux alentours de
2800 et plus qui a des avantages centré
sur internet masse en gros le blitz sur
internet et les parties longues ces deux
jeux différents
disons qu'il ya rsa il était très fort
en partie on va dire on à partir de
partie en 30 secondes où il était
vraiment impressionnant jusqu'aux
parties en trois minutes dans ces
parties là il avait vraiment un jeu
incroyable maintenant jouer en 3 minutes
ou jouer en 3h30
c'est pas parce que c'est pas pareil
quoi c'est pas pareil c'est des
ouvertures différentes c'est une manière
de jouer différente des qualités un peu
différente
donc après ça se ressemble évidemment
mais comme on parlait de vélo tout à
l'heure il ya des alaphilippe il est
très très fort c'est un très très bon
puncheur après tu le mets sur le col de
la lose
il va un peu souffrir quoi ça n'empêche
pas que ce soit un bon cycliste mais
voilà faut travailler un peu
différemment et voilà vous parlez aussi
de jalabert tout à leur compte ils
étaient très bons sprints il était bon
au sprint après quand il a gagné la
vuelta il faisait pas forcément le même
poids et il n'avait pas forcément le
même entraînement c'est un peu ça ce
cash 4 un couard h4 pense qu'ils doivent
avoir peur de ça avec le cavalier qui va
revenir en f4 c'est vraiment très
effrayant
de f5 et prend f5 opposition plus sympa
à jouer pour les noirs ceux qui ont tous
le jeu devant le roi
mais f4 ouais enfin peut-être après fo
sur kavala boeuf 4 ça peut-être juste
des prises à multiples en f4 1 c'est
dangereux prise va reprendre de 1 quand
même reprendre de la dame et faire h4
ben y'a cavalli prend parlons jean
conneries il doit faire rage est il
obligé de faire agir wager sept tours à
schwyz qui va arriver
salut gaby gab mais bon il ya ce fou ces
deux qui qui parle encore mia le pion g4
qui se retrouvent est esseulé d'ailleurs
âgées il peut faire dame prend g4 prise
est prise comme quoi là j'ai
complètement raté ce truc-là fait il
perd le pion
en réalité il perd le pion à ses dames
pranger karamé a peut-être damas six
échecs attendait d'alger cadarache six
cavaliers h 3à n'y a pas qu'à l'est les
pro 3 iliad engrangé 6 échecs et oui
fonctionne pas ça ne fonctionne pas donc
là
ike qui a retourné la situation il va
devoir échanger les dames et une
nouvelle fois il se met à mal autant
niall faudrait pas qu'ils le regrettent
impasse qui domine bien il domine quand
même bien ce cette première phase de jeu
il a fait qu'un voyage froid tempo voilà
ça fait mal le cavalier h3 tempo il
n'avait pas du tout venir al niall le
carré d'as 3 et la dame étrangers six
échecs bêtement c'est une pièce non
airois g2 je vois pas où est le problème
en fait
ok il a juste craquer complètement fou
ces deux essais juste une pièce de moins
fougueux 4-1 d'ailleurs les foucades
peut-être cahier des deux aurait fait
j'aurais mis le fou ans et de
m'apprendre à fo katia des 5 au 6 e 4
fonctionne au salaire bien à yaffo h5
aussi prénom il ya eu quelques cases
intéressante cavaliers des deux est
peut-être un cavalier g5 pendant fou des
cinq à trois ou quatre ans des cinq
d'ailleurs et tourache un courage 7
autour des 1 encore mieux en ferme en
ferme le cavalier et gagne la partie
ouais ouais nian nian qui peut regretter
un il va rester deux parties dans la
cadence
franchement après les positions qu'il a
eue dans les ouvertures trois et demi
deux ans et demi c'est pas cher payé
pour pour ike surtout qu'il a gaffé dans
la première il a quand même donné il a
fini par donner une part tu pouvais
prendre là nul on à hilard craqué après
dans une autre partie là où il y avait
la finale tour fou contours cavaliers
donc il a quand même craqué à deux
reprises
notre ami haïk et où il a craqué deux
demi point et finalement il reste à
portée de fusil alors qu'il est moins
bien dans toutes les parties et ouais on
a l'impression que que niall commence à
être un petit peu emprunté ils
pourraient ils pourraient le regretter
ça surtout qu'on l'a vu qu'ils pouvaient
être fatigué après qu'on leur passé et
que peut-être au moment du but l'at il
serait plus à 100% c'est des points qui
peut regretter des points laissés en
cours de route
2 mes affaires qu'il est [ __ ] cet essai
5 non ça doit être l'idée standard à
eric schimdt peut-être à b5 et c5 ou à
ces cinq directes pour mettre le
cavalier en c6 est peut-être c5
maintenant pour moi que lecavalier en c6
cavale et b17 way avec le c5 qui va
partir hors du coup de tête sur est
jouée kébé s'est faite b5 du coup un peu
un bon est-ce qu'il peut faire c'est 5
puis on prend et peut-être bouger la
dame après avant de récupérer en c5 ça
paraît quand même un peu un peu spéciale
pour ces 8 et peut-être un rhénan to
secure est en phase aller il fait ses 5
et peut-être du coup pions projet fou
prend ce qu'on pourra pas reprendre du
cavalier à cause de fou prend arrive cet
échec et tout reprendre et 8
donc il doit faire fou prend
voir ce que ça donne cavalier g 500
prend un peu au roi fut raffy si le
cavalier e41 clairement touché le foot
ou chez les cavaliers après c'est pas
forcément grave un don qui a fait
cavalier 4 et il va y avoir quoi donc
faire quoi il va échanger dans les faits
dame b si ce qui laisse le fou mais il
veut viser la case 4 il laisse le fou
mais il veut viser la case de 4
les français 5e france et 5 tours des
8es visé révisé de 4 avec les avec les
chevaux
on va voir à 4 pour affaiblir et met à
quatre baies quatre jours la même
histoire après c'est jouable en tête
avec 2 à 5 mai à 4 b 4 et du coup on
s'en prend à ton cavaliers et si on met
quatre sera bien placé un truc qui prend
5 et prend simple saddam peut venir en
c6 un jour se mettre en batterie
je crois que le record de précocité pour
devenir gm en france c'est plutôt
etienne bacrot 1 qu'il avait pas mvl non
mais un cadre des quartiers france 5 ça
va pas du tout tristan gamer c'est ça
appartient pas une racaille france et 5
et ses passages aux arméniens qui jouent
à je pense que pkp sa valeur juste très
fort il a fait à 4 mai b4 ça me paraît
fort c'est moi qui suis complètement fou
hein le b46 en france et 5 et prend ses
cinq ça me paraît juste parfait à 4-1
goût que j'ai vraiment pas compris
honnêtement et il n'ya leur fait une
tête bizarre après sept prix b4
juste pour dire l'évaluation de l'ordi
est passé de +0 40 à moins 1 est
vraiment à 4 b 4 le truc c'est que à 5
adams et 6 et on vise ici c'est un
problème et qui avait laissé cinq essais
cinq ans fait du coup on se retrouve
attaqué de partout bas donc du coup
maintenant il prend m6 mais ça fait
aucun sens et caribéens et donc là ça
fait vraiment aucun sens qu'il a fait il
a donné b4 gratuit il a échangé les
cavaliers il en était obligé 1 mais
maintenant genre dame sait si ça peut
faire mal f3 va être forcé elle alors
didonne e st caprais avec france 5 tours
8 qui est très dur à trouver pour aller
s'en prendre à eux trois sasa gagnerait
ça peut être trouvable remarque un
puisque f3c force et sa dame et ses 6 tu
as envie de le jouer pour ce qui peut
aussi faire d'un mets fins mais ça
commence à être très bizarre normalement
if3 et e5 tu peux le trouver après
parce que j'en refais ou prend aux 5
tours 8 donc il fait que quatre mais là
il ya cavale et prend le cadre tout
bêtement il a peut-être vu e 5 sur f3
d'ailleurs après ça doit briller jusqu'à
et prend 4 non fou prend 1,4 dame prend
1,4 voilà l'enchaînement à 4-4 et
terrible hein maintenant là c'est
terrible
voilà après tristan of gamer nyala fait
la même mais c'est vrai que j'ai du coup
si coup après il a un pion de moins et
l'autre à la paire de fou de un peu
mieux il est passé à complètement perdre
en l'espace de trois coups quoi c'est
terrible c'est terrible voilà c'est bien
joué b3 yacht est fou c'est roi fou
prend fou prend b3 et il peut se faire
égaliser
il peut se faire égaliser dans cette
partie est ce qui est terrible pour lui
s'il se fait égaliser c'est vraiment un
tord à l'impression d'avoir dominé le
début de match et tu vas quand même te
faire égaliser et on a l'impression
qu'ils jouent de moins en moins bien
aussi ce qui peut être inquiétant
ouais les records de précocité pour
devenir grand maître magnifique chaises
sont pas forcément ce pape forçant pas
ce que tu deviens le plus jeune grand
maître de l'histoire que tu deviens
champion du monde ou que tu deviens le
plus fort rouleur du monde magnus il
doit être dans les plus jeunes mais
c'est pas jeu peut-être qu'il n'est même
pas dans le top 3 non c'est non un match
à haut et très loin là c'est très très
long j'ai 5 fu et trois tours à ses 8
il veut faire tour à sept tours 17 il
veut pas faire le g5 ce qu'ils se
gardent cinq sous le coude
c'est un bon indicateur oui mais sur ce
site et grand maître à 15 ans tu vas
forcément ou à 13 ans forcément tu as
père c'est parce que déjà de grands
maîtres c'est bien mais ça veut pas dire
que tu seras champion du monde pour
autant même que tu seras dans le top 10
mondial
est-ce que ça m'est déjà arrivé de
m'endormir devant un match si je vais
commenter pas oui là je mens je pourrais
m'endormir ouais enfin pas en écoutant
mes qualités mes commentaires qualitatif
mais sinon oui
tour 17 samana sera fou prend b3 tour
reprend 17 est fou c'est 4 mhz et
oreillers to receive aux camaïeux 3
ce que les meilleurs joueurs du monde
sont aspergés aspergé de quoi amis n'ont
pas forcément alors
d'origine et ce qu'ils sont aspergés
d'eau aspergé de peinture où j'en sais
rien moi
alors du coup sûr f4 sur laquelle il
prend des 5
donc il ya la fourchette ne fonctionne
pas fou prend b3 du coup il ya plus du
tout guidé puisque la tour est protégée
après la question c'est est ce qu'on
rentre là dedans parce que souvent il
peut pas il ya toujours échangé la
finale de pions doit être gagnante
et ça ça donne quoi en fait ça donne
envie un tour sur la deuxième qui ont de
plus et ben c'est la partie justement
c'était la question qu'on pouvait se
poser ce qu'on range là dedans ou pas et
il y a répondu favorablement mais
normalement tu eu 5 3 6 3 des 5 le
problème pas le pion plus un c'est la
tour la tour baladeuses il va monter le
roi petit à petit regardez la différence
d'activité des rois et là il veut
peut-être dire que sur tours d2 la
finale est pas clair mais il a peut-être
tourbe et deux tons prend b3 tour des
six il va échanger
allez va récupérer à 6 n'y a pas tord gm
ce qui a le fou qui protège qui peut pas
venir sans prendre option g2 leroy qui
vend des trois temps plongé de tout
reprend h 6 arrêts ça paraît quand même
bien pour le joueur arménien après il
peut décider de faire tour à 8 avec
l'idée d'en bas il envoie le pion
j'adore ce que fait nyala l'ania y joue
très bien en défense il va faire tout
rejet 3 j'imagine tour à 2 fawcett
retour des deux est le 4è tour à deux
ils s'étaient peut-être un peu planté il
a trouvé cette idée après de créer le
pion pas cf qui en avance 1 sur m6
aujourd'hui elle fous ces trois ans
puisqu'ils contrôlent la case f6 pour le
retour de la tour et ça semble être
l'égalisation qui se dessine pour le
joueur aux médias alors ils calculent
quand même ici eh bien oui sur foot
france et roya f1 dame sur échec
et là-dessus tour des 3 et f1 dame ces
dames de plus pour le joueur armenia qui
égalise les amis avec martirossian qui
revient au score
j'ai presque mois en vigueur contre le
cours du jeu
il s'est vraiment nourrit un des erreurs
de niall sarine il a il n'a pas fait de
jeu à haïti mais a toujours était pour
va dire par mois pas moins bien dans les
participants à la tension ne pas faire
qui est des ceintures et caïds et 6 matt
petit piège s'est pas fait payer un tout
petit peu derrière pas de beaucoup quoi
tu peux dire que plus un ce serait le
score normal pour pour niall ici mais
c'est vrai que il s'est nourri des
erreurs adverses il n'a pas vraiment
fait le jeu il est plutôt attentistes et
pas vraiment le mot est plutôt un peu
derrière au début et puis il résiste
pendant longtemps alors là et ce cas il
faut prendre ces deux j'imagine qu'il ya
des trois à chaque fois un qui enferme
alors délicat et damas cinq échecs du
coup maintenant
français c'était quand même un peu
culotté en tout cas il a joué tempo il
n'a pas pris et jouer avec damas 5 et
les joueurs peuvent se voir wade
gianelli tv bon alors il reste il reste
quatre minutes dans la section savate
cette partie là dernière là je pense
qu'on va faire foi ou fous ces 3 j'avais
plutôt fois un perso ce que vous ces
trois fous des quatre fois je vois pas
l'intérêt de replacer sous en b 4 ans à
3 il est pas très bien et l'a d'ailleurs
fou bkt peut-être pas pas forcément à ce
coup là mais va être une idée de leur
enlever le fou est peut-être essayer de
passer le cavalier verbe et 4 alors
maintenant une des questions c'est
toujours de savoir est ce qu'on peut
faire cavaler h4 pour s'emparer du four
peut aussi jouer peut-être avec à puget
trois fous j'ai deux pour passer le fou
ici il fait hacher trois fous j'ai deux
parties richard est une perruque pour
déstabiliser son adversaire
l'art est un peu fatigués martirossian
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs il n'a pas une
tête aussi a aussi tranquille que
d'habitude après c'est vrai qu'il ya une
situation compliquée en arménie en ce
moment ma part m'a pas parlé de guerre
ou quoi parce qu'on a déjà passé les
sujets un peu désagréable mais on peut
on peut imaginer que la vie ne soit ne
soit pas pas si paisible pour lui en ce
moment
art
ce qui va jouer fou j'ai deux ici faire
gaffe à lons dépassement d'un cahier des
quatre qui est processes damas six qui
peut traîner cavaliers d-4d j'imagine
fou j'ai dehors il est quand même parti
pour
je pensais qu'il garderait l'option qui
avait les h4 pour pour prendre le fou de
cases blanches mais je pense qu'il a
pris la décision de mettre un pion
détroit pour pour faire un petit mur
devant
vous pensez y si ce peut être une idée
mais puis on prend cavaliers prend et un
coup de dames blog bien les velléités
blanche h4 avec l'idée de faire h salon
qui va faire h5 ça c'est sûr c'est qu'il
veut il veut il veut péter un truc
quelque part un essai un tournoi ray
placer les demi finales d'un tournoi
entre juniors
fou et 4 d'accord alors ce qu'il veut
faire c'est affaiblir le curage 5 juste
pour dire un coup comme fouet f3 menacé
pas le pion h5 parce que la dame protège
il est doublement protéger ce pion et f4
pour qu'ils fassent f5 f4 peut être une
option est aussi jusqu'à t'aurais pu
être un coup mais faut toujours faire
gaffe à 2,5
quand tu fais ça ouais c'est accepter à
leur ouvre maintenant nacac film c'est
son deuxième écran alors que tu peux
juste avoir une oreillette et avoir
quelqu'un qui dit les coups je vois pas
l'intérêt en fait flouer ktef 5 et
surtout f3 il veut 5
il veut cette idée là et lecavalier n'a
plus de gaz ouais c'était assez marrant
rouge j'ai trouvé ça vérifie tellement
rien de filer le deuxième écran c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment très drôle ça
j'ai trouvé ça très comique perso j'ai
trouvé ça très comique de filmer le
deuxième écran serait qui sert à rien
qui prouve rien de rien mais bon
pourquoi pas hein c'est juste commis qui
sait et non j'ai rien fait regardez je
suis le monde deuxième écran ce bailleur
qui l'a fait quoi que ce soit mais je
trouve ça assez infantile peut pas
prendre ces 6 1
j'en suis entraîné sans nom mais le plus
simple c'est la technique avait fait
même montré vlad j'ai souvent parlé de
cette vidéo youtube mais il ya des
micros il avait loué sa pour 50 euros
par jour ils pouvaient louer et je crois
qu'à la chasse a coûté 800 à 850 euros à
l'époque il ya 5 6 ans de france existe
juste eu vous perdre une classe hein les
gars depuis tout à l'heure et est du
coup c'est un truc complètement
minuscule mais c'est vraiment minuscule
à il m'avait montré une photo ça tient
vraiment ces minuscules et tu le mets
dans l'oreille en fait
et alors là tu peux mettre 40 40
millions de caméras si tu veux c'est
absolument invisible alors vraiment
invisible de chars visible c'est
vraiment tout petit ça se glisse entre
l'oreille un plan sous la pauvre ya
plein de technique en fait vu les
centaines de milliers voire les millions
d'euros en jeu maintenant dans les
tournois en ligne
le deuxième écran serait la pire
technique parce que ce serait celle
qu'on pourrait voir quand on met des
lunettes ou par inadvertance et ya des
réflexions voile et compléterait non
seulement des gens non non ça peut être
honnête c'était justement le sens de la
vidéo de vlad ckpa de ya pas de
vérification pour ce genre d'engin dans
l'est dans les compétitions réel donc
c'est facilement employables après c'est
risqué parce que tu peux bon c'est quand
même pas sur internet a aucun risque de
te faire prendre vraiment 0 % de chances
de se faire prendre
nous sommes cinq dames 3 donc c'est la
dame
partie du segment le chronomètre est
terminé en 11e position qui tourne
depuis tout à l'heure il faut toujours
vérifier les cailles processus qui
peuvent marcher là ce coup là d'ailleurs
ça aurait pu être un plus intéressant
serait plus regardée dans le sens où on
avait enfin le damas six échecs ça
aurait pu ça ça pouvait fonctionner un
ça peut être ça pouvait être dans le
dans le règne du march abl mais après on
oublie trop dur à calculer
dames bs6 donc ça lui évite d'avoir à
n'importe quel problème de découverte ce
qu'il est protégé par le lion cependant
faire gaffe de passe prendre un fou à 5
1 jour moi je me suis déjà pris avec une
dame en d2 pour ça que j'en parle mais
là ça a l'air d'aller
le foot hier par an à schwyz diable et
cavaliers pros f5 afu prend donc ça va
mais tata tellement de deux trucs qui
peuvent rodez faut être hyper méfiant ce
que si kiev f ça qu'on devait faire
pions prend il y avait dame prend 1,8
prise reprise est prise en âge suite
mais ses protégés pour le moment par le
four
cavalier e de aussi impossible pour
créer les échanges il fait à 4 way sur
cinq la cave a lieu devrait dans tous
les cas ce que qu'a eue de l'idée
c'était cavalière 4 x 3 kg pour 1 h 5
qui peut qui peut être fait à long terme
ce pur h5 peut être un problème car en
faut de nouveau faire gaffe si
lecavalier bouge aux découvertes
il fait à 5 ils chassent cavalia 2 est
toujours dans la rif et cavalières 3 km
de kayak 4t toujours en l'air mais
peut-être de5 et là maintenant fuhe 5 ça
paraît cool sur dame prend 1,5 à damas
est et qui finit par rentrer avec sa
dame 6,5 russe là bas c'est dangereux
donc il a fait karel yeux cinq cavaliers
g4 ça va échanger
il va pouvoir reprendre des faits serait
ouvrir le fou donc pas des changements
g4 il faut dame c5
alors il veut quoi il veut prendre quand
il veut il veut maintenir la pression
n'y a pas de menace concrète prise cinq
lettres tout reprend est intéressant ici
et qui des cavaliers prend fou prend est
rentré en ascète ouais ouais ça c'est
très bien joué le tour prend sa santé là
qu'il ya des choses qui rôdent avec les
pièces blanches trop bien placé et il
menace est f3 cavaliers prend fou prend
et damas est si la dame s'introduit en b
8 ça risque d'être fini on va gagner 17
et c5 et tour des cinq maintenant très
bien joué de la part de niall sarine
parce que sur fou prend des saints qui
avait dame prend 1,5
excellemment défendu de la part du
joueur indien mais qui se retrouve un
peu mal après fou prend f3 un peu moins
bien parce qu'il ya toujours ce pion h5
en l'air et si les blancs réussissent à
faire froid c'est un des trois rois des
200 que le roi noir ne s'infiltre trop
ça peut être fantastique donc il fait
plutôt roi b2 pour essayer d'avoir du
roi c3 pour empêcher la rentrée du roi
et maintenant il va il va ramener petit
à petit son roi dont 4,4 jouer pour
s'activer effet retour f6 c'est très
bien joué les blancs pas eu le temps de
ramener leurs droits en d2 et d'empêcher
l'arrivée du roi noir donc là la
position semble
être maintenant on est toujours un peu
mieux pour les blancs mais ca se dessine
- peut-être un petit coup de g4 pour
créer un pion h passées fou etc a très
bien joué il va y avoir foule prend
hélas sur qui on prend il ya tourache 6
donc il doit faire g5
il ya du e3 qui va partir donc faut
ramener le roi a eu 3 qui part qu' on
prend tout reprend autour des 3 ou là
trois c4 est là c'est le roi noir qui
qui rentre et regardez le pion des cats
qui sert à rien alors que de l'autre
côté et la tour 4 qui doit gagner la
finale pour prendre pour des cas tout
reprend roi prend et ça ça gagne
tranquille le pion le pion fils adam
final très mal géré cette fois ci de la
part de nike aurait d'ailleurs il est un
peu dégoûté il a joué pour gagner une
nouvelle fois et c'est ça rime qui gagne
finalement on va dire que le score
correspond à la physionomie du match
plus simple pour le joueur indien
mais c'est vrai que là il s'est retrouvé
très mal trois c4 c'était bizarre mais
tour des trois tours prend des 3 ou
apprend des trois là il avait le temps
mais j'imagine voulait tour j'ai trois
rois des deux rois au cices a été
terrible tout reprend j'ai trois pions
pranger 3 3 3 3 des 5 3 3 pour apprendre
des 4 c'est fini
bon écoute et match assez sympathique un
finalement à suivre match serré avec
avec les deux joueurs qui ont un qui ont
un bon niveau
avec 1 avec un niveau de jeu assez sympa
de la part des deux hommes vous êtes
moches les maigrichon qui joue aux
échecs maintenant toi t'es beau ballon
de foot j'ai peur que ballon de foot
soit très moche en fait et qui
complexent compliqué très compliqué pour
le chat match très sympathique way
compliqué de ballons de foot qui
complexent ça arrive ça arrive hein
rita sont à son pseudo règle ces
intellos va lui présenter masoe
ouais c'est marrant il est pas venu
méchamment quoi il n'est pas venu
méchamment derrière la tête de ce top
model ray amel est venu un peu on peut
voir comme ça provoque emea
mais voilà bon esprit mon esprit
esprit et sa large succès
alors ça va reprendre l'an dans cinq six
minutes je vais attendre avec vous à
voir comment ça se passe ce deuxième
deuxième tiers-temps
stark falco qui a dit bonjour il s'est
pris un vent aïe aïe aïe
j'enchaîne avec le 3 way on va faire
l'enchaînement
il ya un bûcheron aussi aux échecs quoi
il ya déjà des grands maîtres avec avec
des sacrés carrure 1 effectivement ce
sera à 21h le prochain 3 sera à 21h vrai
icaro qui est déjà en train de stream et
des viewer arena mais qui sera en pleine
forme pour le tournoi après ça ne lui
posera aucun problème karpatchev
bûcheron karpatchev karpatchev plus que
buffon karpatchev hooligans à 16h
supporters de foot que j'arrête pas trop
croisée en tribune qui donne pas très
envie d'être croisés en tribune
mais karl seine doit avoir un coach
sportif ou et maxime aussi d'ailleurs tu
as raté je suis pas tombé l'avant dinan
karpatchev fait pas tomber la pendule
complètement karpatchev tu fais rien
tombé du tout et ça lui en fait vous me
lisez cette chaîne rai chaze car event
en ça c'est sûrement parce que ouais
parce qu'en fait si les gens ils voient
la notification speech et juniors ils
vont pas cliquer du coup il veut lancer
le truc sur une chaise comme après c'est
clairement l'idée
tu laisses jouer sur ton temps
exactement chenapan tapis sur ta propre
pendule et tu laisse réfléchir quoi
c'est complètement ça les amis
karpatchev t'emmène palou en face à
aimer bon karpatchev c'est karpatchev à
sepa doivent qui est menacée chez peak
avec un marteau si chez plus ni carouge
parce qu'ils avaient foutu way we gonna
il massacra du tout enfin il fait il
fait pas très peur en vrai moi que je
les ai déjà vus en vrai franchement il
fait pas très peur
franchement il fait pas
rêveur
ces chevaux 3 de bois vrai karpatchev il
vaut à fait plus peur que trois au beauf
réuni way largement c'est la pause 38
basset pause de dix minutes le rallye
sans base
c'est la pause de 10 minutes c'est ce
que j'ai en tout cas pas tu vois je le
connais bien car pas de chef
il sent pas
enfin moi je
après mais des même tatouage non il est
sympa karpatchev way
alors
ça devrait bientôt reprendre
mais si quelques lieder quelques
secondes mais peut-être pas quelques
secondes mais dans une ou deux minutes
ça devrait reprendre les joueurs se sont
ré à 6 les joueurs se sont ré à s'y
faire un des joueurs céréales si du coup
série qu on va pouvoir enfin suivre
maxime j'espère que ce match finissent
pas trop tard déjà une heure 45 1 deux
matches on doit être un peu moins de la
moitié
saric selon sébastien sans déconner
c'est loin
non mais vraiment un
c'est reste plus que deux demi-finales
et une finale donc tu dis ok on arrive
au bout mais sinon c'est vrai que c'est
loin
y'a pas à dire en revanche c'est pour un
an mais en fait pas parler là pendant
1h45
mais c'est vrai quand tu dis en 1h45 de
match on est à peine à la moitié
c'est terrible en fait mentalement tout
ça pour les joueurs le vent qui commande
pour les gens qui suivent c'est
compliqué quoi
quel est parti qu'ils reprennent dans
une minute on serait dans un match de
sport us way est encore le basket je
trouve que c'est assez dynamiques comme
sport pour la peine
piggy résumé femme ça fabrice séparé qui
commentent ouais moi aussi je pique un
peu du nez en vrai je sais pas comment
je fais pour regarder à
pour garder la forme se tient mieux
supporter moralement merci à blue et pig
par mes cheveux je sais pas honnêtement
si je si je referai les commentaires de
tous ces tournois la saison prochaine
parce que c'est vrai c'est vrai que je
me ressens pas refaire une saison de ces
tournois la saison prochaine je referai
pas un triplé speech est féminin speech
and junior etc
c est ce pitch est réel ou quoi c'est
juste pas possible en fait ouais non
c'est juste que j'ai peur de ne plus
aimer les échecs après je vous le dis
franchement 1 c'est un peu décalée à la
came c'est pas grave à le décaler
manuellement
maintenant j'aimerais sans rigoler en
plus la no no no trop lent plus j'ai
peur à force ce thème thèmes plus les
échecs à force de voir ça
si le format changes où il c'est
différent mais si le format change en
fait changent pas j'ai peur que après un
moment donné en fait juste a plus envie
de voir des chèques
ouais les speechs absence et c'est
quelque chose qui oeuvrent pour ces dans
le délire de kochi kaïn quoi les speechs
sc là c'est la continuité de coach
hicheim quoi pour être bien sûr que les
gens je vous fais aux échecs
kouichi kane pré-lehman jeu martirossian
c'est cool parce qu'au moins tu as ton
petit poulain et espère qu'ils gagnent
ont tout à l'heure il avait réussi à
bien retourner la position c'est logique
qu'il y retourne martirossian bien
qu'ils avaient pas très bien joué la
position que chicken et vous voulez des
nouveaux formats pour tournoi appelé
kôji kane après les speech est de 3h30
le nouveau format 8 heures de cinq plus
un diseur de 3 + 1 et 14 heures de bus
l'aide pour finir vous serez bien sûr
que le meilleur gagne ici à moins de 25
points d'écart à la fin c'est pas grave
on repart pour 72 heures de jeu non-stop
ne vous inquiétez pas le meilleur
gagnera vous en avez marre de devoir
vous en avez marre de devoir organiser
des compétitions tous les ans c'est pas
grave avec le nouveau format vos
compétitions dureront huit ans à la fin
c'est même plus le meilleur junior qui
gagne c'est le champion du monde en
titre la fin de votre compétition le
meilleur junior sera à la retraite
ouais le marathon de 24 heures je le
proposais ouais si vous avez des idées
de mauvais format n'hésitez pas
n'hésitez pas à m'en faire part
il faut que ça puisse passer quoi faut
que ce soit réaliste
si vous avez des idées de formats
vraiment pour av
mais qui peuvent éventuellement passer
genre pas 10 heures de 5 + 1 ça ça
hum ça ça n'a pas fonctionné il faut il
faut vraiment un format qui puissent
qu'ils puissent être acceptés quoi pour
vraiment si vous avez des idées toutes
vos pires idées en fait mais qui
pourrait marcher n'hésitez pas à m'en
faire part
tu auras partie différée ils ont tenté
jo sox et on m'a proposé d'y participer
donc ça en fait ça a déjà été fait
on commence par deux parties fines
rights as a voulu être fait bas qui
envoient une réalité mais ça n'a pas
fonctionné mais il ya eu cette idée de
faire des tournois détourna deux parties
longues sur internet et ça n'a pas
marché malheureusement mais l'idée
l'idée l'idée a déjà germé ouais donc en
fait bac il a tu donnes une vraie idée
qui qui a vraiment existé quoi partie
longue mais tu joues plusieurs défis en
même temps ça on devrait quand même
daniel ça peut passer
franchement s'il ya quelqu'un qui peut
me l'envoyer sur discordants mpsl la
merci kamel daniel ça c'est une vraie
idée qui peut passer franchement salage
la propose no fake je la propose je vais
dire excellente idée du tchat et où j'ai
trouvé ça très bien joué en partie un
speech est en partie longue mais avec
quatre cinq parties en même temps
franchement sallèles et bien qu'à ma
dernière elle peut passer ses idées de
génie de tapas en fait
excellente idée de kaman daniel dans le
chat qui vient de qui vient de
s'échapper un aux yeux de tous
les pions qui bouge sur le côté ça
pourrait passer ça aussi je sox mais
faut un format bien l'on en fait
est-ce qu'on peut utiliser plusieurs
hanjin hanjin si on joue plus à repartir
ouais ouais tu peux avoir plusieurs ordi
et illizi et plusieurs en jeans horaire
mais j'espère que tu es pour
martirossian baky 83 à j'espère que le
pakistan indépendant et supporters de
martirossian dans ce match j'espère que
notre ba qui est sérieux pas le choix
bien sûr
bataj ses joueurs sélectionnent qu'un
joueur constitution équipé nouveau
joueur différent à chaque tour
pas bêtes pas bêtes dans mes tripes
caméra on savait les caméras les caméras
y'a pas fou prend à trois là a été
éprouvée 5 sûrement mois il veut il veut
le truc de 5,4 ils les jouent mieux que
ni al sani les joues mal ses positions
bas qu'ici tu dois te préparer contre ni
alain jour ce genre de pose là
tout à l'heure il nous a fait un acat
mythique dans cette position et hub et
cat il était perdant quatre coups après
et là encore une fois tu as l'impression
que il est complètement perdue en fait
dans ces genres de cela vous tatou qui
s'échangera d'être complètement perdus
fouet fuite
mais joue le cap d'agde dans le online
écoute il a l'air de matchs joués ces
trucs là je les joue mal oui mais ils
les jouent encore plus mal que toi lâche
en clis ou qu'ils se racontent qu'ils se
rappellent de la mythique punchline de
vlad
en fait ce qui est beau dans cette peine
thaïs et qui met une punchline à anne en
dit long mais aussi une grosse armure
tasse en fait parce qu'il lui dit pas
non tu les joues quand même pas si mal
où il joue moins bien que toi ou je sais
pas ou si tu les joues mal c'est dire
qu'en fait il il confirme en fait l'idée
de mur tu as oui je suis bien
complètement nul
c'est ça qui est beau c'est ça le plus
beau dans cette histoire pas ça à l'air
d'être assez égal ce truc maintenant ten
dam c2 ou d'abus 6 tu repars es tu veux
attaquer comme ça mais bon c'est un peu
optimiste encore dame f6 tour des six
ait choqué en fait ouais mais c'était
complètement débile en fait ce qui vient
de faire le truc c'est qu'il est souvent
un poil moins bien il égalise
et après au lieu de prendre là nul il
parle il parle dans du n'importe quoi
ben slimane qui va devenir grand mât et
ouais bah écoute ça fait ça fait un
moment qu'il a le niveau pour l'être
mais la callas gentil nimani ladite 16
17 18 ans non après c'est bien c'est pas
le genre c'est pas un record de
précocité non plus quoi 17 way 17 et il
peut pas faire bessette avec arrêt non
mais attends h 5 h 6 maintenant ça gagne
je pense h 5 3 et cette force et h 6 est
survenu entre entourage suite à mes h si
le roi g6 pardon pardon pardon je
n'avais point vue à et donc on ramène le
roi ici et h6 maintenant
est 3g 7 h 8 et surtout rachat je suis
damerey voilà c'est complètement finie
ike qui a encore une nouvelle fois très
mal joué oui non c'est bien d'ailleurs m
à 17 ans un jeu c'est une belle
performance mais je veux dire c'est
voilà team qui va plus sur un team team
blessés les gars y reste we have signed
celui qui est 3300 bullet ouais là je
pense qu'il est en train de faire
l'écart fait en début de match plutôt ça
rime qui a mal joué et qui s'est nourri
un peu des erreurs c'est ça rime qui
jouait bien et martirossian qui s'est
nourri des quelques petites erreurs
qu'ils faisaient et depuis est depuis en
fait martirossian là il vient de donner
deux points dans les finales
enfin un point deux fois au lieu de nuit
lippert
mais normalement s et ça rime qui va
gagner c'est décevant on espère quand
même encore un sur deux jours arménien
white hirai qui tire la tronche ouais
c'est ce que j'ai premier projet de
passer grand maître non pas du tout
professeur fafa j'ai abandonné ce projet
il ya bien longtemps
il pas blessé mais il a du marais mais
gaston car de bien jouer l'air d'être
doué un joueur français
je sais pas quel âge il a fait voir je
vais jeter un oeil
ça va être un joueur très doué il a 20
ans et un jeune 20 ans est un jeune
joueur qui pourrait peut-être l'avenir
du tennis français après après que parce
que 1 bert et mouthe et moi j'y crois
pas trop perso ce projet m'a traversé la
tête de venir dire oui il ya une
quinzaine d'années vingt ans il ya 20
ans oui il ya dix ans entre 17 et 20 ans
m'a traversé l'esprit way après j'ai
pris deux j'ai fait d'autres choix de
vie qui je pense était été les bons en
tout cas je sais pas c'était les bons
choix du ou pas ce qui est sûr c'est que
passé gm aurait été un mauvais choix a
posteriori salon sur ça j'en suis sûr
mais il n'est encore pas très bien avec
un il n'a pas le sens on a l'impression
qu'ils jouent avec les noirs en fait
c'est terrible
enfin qui a fait le mauvais choix non
peut-être qu'il a fait le bon choix pour
lui un sapré c'est tout un chacun par
rapport à son caractère ou quoi mais eux
j'aime pas assez les échecs en partie
longue pour avoir passé ma vie pour être
2005 quoi serait pas été possible il n'y
a pas de bon ou de mauvais choix dans
l'absolu non il ya des choix qui rendent
plus heureux que d'autres mais ça c'est
sûr c'est un choix de vie qui m'aurait
pas rendu heureux ça c'est évident
j'aime pas du tout les parties longues
et ça aurait été un énorme problème en
fait de tout donner pour pas être si
fort prête à des sportifs qui aime pas
du tout leur sport comme par exemple
agassi qu'il l'a dit mais après comme il
est devenu numéro un mondial est tout
après avec le temps ça va mais mais moi
j'aimais vraiment pas vraiment les
parties longues et du coup à passer ma
vie pour faire ça et pas être très fort
ça aurait été un problème
une bonne situation jour à chaque
professionnel bas ça dépend si tu es
dans les meilleurs mondiaux oui
alexander oublier quoi et alors manaudou
il ya plein de gens en fait mais mais
mais on va dire que si tu arrives dans
les meilleurs ça peut se justifier mais
si tu végète à la 400e place mondiale
c'est abusé
du coup j'aime bien vite c'est en fait
si si si il y avait eu un changement de
cadence
quand j'avais 16-17 ans en fait je pense
que j'aurais continué les échecs
clairement clairement jours avec
continue en fait ce que j'adorais les
beats et les semi rapide est clairement
si cécile beats ou le semi rapide était
là était la cadence était la cadence
classique entre guillemets 1,6 avait été
là la cadence la plus jouée j'aurais
clairement continuer
c'est la cadence qui acquit à qui a
aiguillé mon choix ouais mais belle
comme pivoine en méga sont en parler un
mac ça ne t'inquiète pas on était sur le
coup est-ce que tout reprend f7 ça peut
être intéressant ici normalement c'est
jamais très bon mais bon faut que des
fautes sur jeter un oeil ce truc là je
le ferai pas c'est pas assez
il a fais d'un rêve 2 mais là j'aime
bien fou c'est de fouler 3 il replace le
fou pour attaquer le pion isoler mellal
pion aux trois qui est problématique et
e4
sur pions prend il y aura t'on point f7
et surtout reprend il ya ton prince est
aussi ça a l'air très fort à ce qu'il a
fait est là tourcoing f7
et tout reprend à sète il veut arriver
il veut fouet trois pardon temps
pressait déjà fou et 3 du coup peut-être
3g 2 avec le cavalier qui couvre 2 ouais
c'est ce qu'ils jouent et surfe ou trois
damage 4 j'imagine voilà tout reprend
bessette qui menace quand même
il va la gagner celle-là je pensais
peut-être d'un match 4 maintenant aller
d'un match 4 ça la bonne tête là a mis à
fouiller cet pardon pardon pardon les
amis le fou qui repart angers7
il le fait quand même fou g7 mais c'est
quoi la suite et ce qui veut tout race
est maintenant il fait tous rêvent de yb
l'inde prise bien jouer la prise pour
pour libérer la diagonale c'est bien
joué de la part de sarine trois jeux
suite il est en préparation il en
préparation pour envoyer pour envoyer
des quatre là l'ordi donne un coup très
dur à trouver ses tours heures avec id
tour prend 20 dames v8 ça c'est
extrêmement difficile il a fait l'âme
ils font un f3 et il va faire un dame
csn j'imagine dans tour de bien jouer
tours 2 il veut se gagner la huitième
fois il et il est bien là il est bien il
va y avoir des dames à huit échecs quoi
il veut il veut réseauter le roi il ya
le temps aussi qui joue h5
il veut quoi il veut damas huit dames e4
bien jouer le petit échec damas huit
dames 4 c'est sûr et tous rêvent cinq
ans est très bien joué il protège et là
il n'y a pas d'âme à 8 à damas huit
dames g6 marche pas ok il reprend et
maintenant il va se prendre la rafale
des chèques qui va essayer de monter le
roi visent à f4 non ah non il va partir
là bas
alors non il peut pas parce qu'il va se
faire prendre en b2 là c'est chaud de
nike qui menacent tour des 8,3 f3ar wife
roya damev 6,3 g ii il ya plus des
chèques non
bref deux il ya trois rois j'ai déjà
plus d'échecs 3g 3 non plus la tour qui
vient dé cette dame g5 roi f3 roi ici
roi ici roi ici roi ici am il a perdu le
pion sur échec
ça doit faire perpète mais c'est quand
même lui qui a plutôt la main avec les
blancs il peut plus près move quoi on va
dire ça comme ça presque
quasi sûr qu'il va y avoir un échec de
la part de l'adversaire et alors que son
adversaire s'est pas forcément il va
mettre son roi mais oui la r pas sûr
qu'à ce noir c'est la mauvaise news
allez une d'amendé si c'est là
maintenant il ya dame b3 et four b2
c'est terrible et fou g5
ouais non mais là martirossian il fit
ils font du vin en arménie là c'est quoi
ces les vendanges il se passe quoi la
martirossian remarques c'est la période
des vendanges
les vendanges en arménie début octobre
le vin le vin le vin va être va être un
peu fort 1 va être un peu fort quand
même
mais là c'est terrible ça fait c'est la
3ème game coup sur coup qui donne moi
c'est les cadeaux c'est lé cas des
arméniens là le père noël arménien est
bien jeune
c'est terrible
at il été là je prends là je pense qu'il
va craquer le machisme le père tout seul
c'est la troisième partie d'affilée où
il peut faire nulle où ils essayent de
gagner ou hyper il y avait trois et demi
trois et demi il vient de faire trois
cadeaux et le problème c'est que plus
plus le match continue puis va être
obligé de forcer et s'il continue à se
casser les dents ça à faire très mal
ça va faire très mal et voilà le tennis
est un sport très difficile à
commentaires pour la peine le tennis est
un sport vraiment compliqué a commenté
parce que si tu joues pas du tout c'est
impossible en fait en fait s'ils jouent
pas du tout tu comprends pas du tout ce
qui se passe je les comprends a compris
ça en mettant à jouer en fait enfin tu
comprends mais tu comprends moins bien
que si tu joues en fait martirossian qui
est pas dedans alors je dirais pas
qu'ils calculent aucun goût camille fait
un bon match mais a mais il lui manque
un peu de précision
ouais au tennis je pense aussi maxime
c'est important d'avoir un consultant
qui a été fort qui était professionnel
je pense aussi ou en tout cas pas
professionnel mais qui ont été top de
1000 atp ou quelque chose comme ça qui a
eu un classement atp et même un point
atp
mais oui c'est important tu me diras
c'est pareil aux échecs en fait j'étais
avec quelqu'un qui sait 117-118 sans
échec c'est un comment table en fait
c'est un commenta bhl
le format classique des cas soit tu dois
avoir un mec qui est vraiment bon et un
mec l'animent bien et pour les échecs
c'est un peu spécial parce que pour
animer faut aussi être bon sinon tu
comprends pas ce qui se passe c'est un
peu c'est un sport un peu spécial or à
part on va dire mais ah mais oui c'est
sale c'est compliqué de commenter en
général et si t'as pas et si tu joues
pas bien pas bien du tout c'est
compliqué aussi
ils ont quel pays ces deux journées
al-saraï ni les indiens et martirossian
et arméniens mais salut à messon dans le
tchat
voilà c'est de nouveau égal alors est-ce
que martyr aussi on va encore déconner
on voit son visage que ça va pas du tout
en
il défend le pion g2 il veut fouet f3 je
pense que martirossian dois juste faire
une nulle dans une partie pour arrêter
l'hémorragie en fait parfois quand tu
perds plusieurs parties d'affilée c'est
bien juste d'arrêter l'hémorragie
il a le temps encore de revenir un ouais
c'est pas évident quand on paye et en
garde je suis complètement d'accord
casar ski puisque non seulement leur
pays en guerre et en plus ils se font
ils se font tous accusé de triche plus
ou moins donc ils ont un double double
problème en ce moment les joueurs
arméniens mais oui évidemment c'est pas
évident de jouer ça c'est ça c'est clair
pour tout le monde
un manque d'expérience trop de presse
pour martirossian mais ça arrive juste
que ça s'enchaîne mal robin des bois en
fait je remarque souvent aussi que les
gens qui ont jamais vraiment fait de
sport de haut niveau pense que c'est
toujours un problème mental mental mais
en réalité parfois c'est juste que ça se
passe comme ça en fait c'est une
question de circonstances souvent enfin
circonstances disons que ça peut être un
enchaînement de choses qui font que tu
vas être mal puis des fois t'es mal
juste parce que tu es mal hein ça arrive
que tu es mal digéré quelque chose et
qui ça tu sois pas à 100% même si t'es
pas vraiment malade ça arrive que tu es
mal dormi la nuit tu sais pas pourquoi
ça arrive que ce jour là je sais pas il
ya des jours peut-être la météo elle a
changé genre moi quand il fait très
chaud puis orage le lendemain en quoi je
peux te fatiguer genre vraiment des
choses enfin fatigué comment dire s'est
pas fatigué en mode tu pourrais pas
travailler ou quoi c'est fatigués en
mode tu vas pas être à 100% tu est à 95%
ou 93 mais quand c'est des matches
serrés ça peut tout changer
tu peux il peut il peut y avoir
tellement de petites choses en fait qui
ont aucun rapport avec le mental ou quoi
qui font que ça peut commencer à mal se
passer et après ce mal s'enchaîner et
après c'est l'histoire des spirales
serre que tu en auras tu es une torah
2 du coup tu te mets à réfléchir etc et
j'ai l'impression que les gens il
interprète toujours ça ouais il n'est
pas bien mentalement il est bien
mentalement mais j'assume c'est que les
gens qui ont jamais fait du sport de
haut niveau qui font ça en faites pas je
sais pas s'il ya la vie de d'autres
personnes qui ont été bien dans une
discipline ou quoi mais j'ai
l'impression que le grand public sur
interprète tellement l'importance du
mental c'est hyper important à mes yeux
c'est sûr c'est sûr interpréter peut y
avoir des jours sans et ça aucun rapport
avec il est pas bien mentalement ou je
sais pas quoi ça peut avoir un rapport
avec des choses mais complètement
différente mais dijon avaler avec et des
jours sans sera là pour tous exactement
si rilov le mental sauveur rei talhouët
c'est vraiment overrated ça existe mais
sauveur right hand ça existe important
et tout mais ce n'est pas l'explication
de tout tout le temps en fait j'étais
issa une fois quand même dans le tennis
une forme mentale énormissime oui mais
nadal s'il est numéro un mondial c'est
pas que le mental en fait c'est juste
qu'il est tellement plus fort que les
autres aussi qui l'a jamais besoin de
sur jouer il est tout le temps contrôler
c'est plus facile d'être bien
mentalement quand tu sais que tu es plus
fort c'est c'est aussi un gros avantage
et à
et au delà de ça aussi une force mentale
ça peut être une force de travail ou
quoi mais ça peut aussi être des choses
qu'on voit pas pendant le match en fait
être quelqu'un de fort mentalement c'est
quelqu'un qui peut s'imposer d'aller
travailler comme un wilkinson qui allait
taper ces pénalités des heures et des
heures et des heures après
l'entraînement et je crois que ronaldo
si c'est un monstre d'entraînement ça
fait partie du mental mais c'est pas le
mental en match c'est le mental d'être
capable de s'imposer un régime de vie
difficiles fait en fait il ya plein de
il ya plein de choses qui rentrent en
compte aussi dans le mental qui est pas
forcément vu et qui sont tout aussi
importantes mais genre là il a raté deux
positions pas forcément le mental
voilà y'a pas d'un premier cas à cavalli
sicile en train de se faire magouilles
et un martirossian il était beaucoup
mieux il ya il ya quelques coups et
maintenant il est moins bien il avait
son pion plus il était mieux
enfin beaucoup mieux j'exagère mais il
avait son petit pion plus tranquille et
maintenant c'est chaud elle est hyper
important de salah pour martirossian
hoya fou des trois ans y avait foule et
3 qui mate et en un il a raté maths en
un il a raté m'attendre il viendra t
m'attendais sarine
donc là encore c'est des circonstances
de match pas une question de mental le
mec tu dois m'attendre un tas primates
en 1 et là tu peux la gagner ou la
perdre ou faire nul mais ça c'est un
truc qui peuvent te remettre dans le
match
là par contre je pense qu'il doit
prendre la nuit doit arrêter de
tergiverser il en a trop perdu fouillez
3 qui a éclaté juste fou pour eux quatre
n'ont pas c'était juste ok c'est m
attend d'eux peut-être mais il a juste
raté m'attendait en fait
attendez je vais vérifier
je vais vérifier mais je crois qu'il a
juste raté m'attendre
attendez info que j'allais retrouver la
partie et en fait ça c'est des choses
qui peuvent te remettre dans le match et
qui ont aucun rapport avec ton mental ou
ton machin ces circonstances de match
bref ou des 3 c'est fini car il ya eu 4
vous prendre quatre matches et surtout
que c'est un coup sur lequel il a
réfléchi il a fait un temps d'arrêt il a
fait fouet f3 et il a raté damev deux
rouages de ici là quand même pas vu dame
france et 2 en 1 re s était pas du grand
niveau
mais bon avec si peu de temps à la
pendule passé l'ordre qui m'a dit d'un
français j'avais pas vu en ont quand
même
mais voilà
c'est typiquement le genre de choses qui
peuvent remettre dans le match non mais
au tennis le fait que les quatre
meilleurs mondiaux y soient plus forts
mentalement peut-être que djoko il prend
aussi le fait de la charge de travail
qui sont capables de s'imposer et c'est
parce qu'un match entre nadal et
ou federer tu prends federer tu le fais
jouer à sa grande époque contre
n'importe quel numéro 5 6 mondial ça
joue pas en mon mental c'est juste en un
qui est plus fort c'est tout et c'est ça
ouais les différents niveaux sont pas
énormes mais mais elles sont exacerbées
par le format ray tu 100% d'accord avec
toi maxime
chose qui s'en alla il refait n'importe
quoi et qui ce qu'il a foutu encore je
comprends pas cavalier c'est du grand
n'importe quoi non non mais quelle
allure c'est juste stupide comme coup
non mais il est vraiment pas dedans
rake
il est vraiment pas dedans
car rien c'est juste grave en fait il
est il est pas dans avec ce soir bon
mais après voilà comme comme ces titres
dans le chatt france franchement laid on
connaît pas trop on connaît pas trop les
circonstances et ses amis
mais bon on voit on voit qu'il est pas
il est pas fond il n'est pas à fond dans
le truck taille n'est pas en forme en
tout cas je trouve le niveau de jeu à
ses fins pas faible mais à mais par
rapport à ce qu'on va voir avec maxime
grille tout que dans une heure et demie
c'est pas terrible
spa table
urgence à se voir physiquement quelque
chose qui va mais bon après c'est
difficile on entend parler de la
situation en arménie depuis nos médias
et tout mais la fin franchement être là
bas en ce moment enfin nous on est
employé l'a pas vu bahia juste
comprendre après c'est marrant ça nous
on en pls quand il ya quand il ya trois
intempéries quoi
et sur un caniveau par avons pas mon
meilleur niveau de jeu ils sont beaucoup
plus forts que moi c'est sûr que c'est
fini cette partie là ces trois pièces
d'écart ça va faire 4 points mais ce qui
est inquiétant c'est pas ça c'est
surtout que hay que là il faille donne
le match justice il n'a pas le niveau
qu'ils habituellement quoi
il n'est pas à son niveau habituel
d'ailleurs il a pas jouer le super
suisse hier ouais il ya peut-être eu
presque aussi peut être affectée par
l'histoire avec petrossian quoi ça donne
dans le cas où ils n'ont pas triché les
arméniens dans le cas de figure où les
arméniens n'ont pas triché ça dégoûtant
fait aussi ce qu'il ya quand même un cas
de figure où ils n'ont pas triché qui
existe un
c'est quand même possible ça dans le cas
où ils n'ont pas triché ça dégoûte un
peu de joie aux siens
il est terrible autour de pièces ce tour
père de fou
possible mais improbable mais possible
salut rue lopez voit malheureusement
imposition et perdu sa affaires + 4 way
mais bon son niveau de jeu est loin de
ce qu'on a pu ce qu'on a pu voir chez
lui gascon confirme 4 à incroyable
talent on l'avait pas vu venir maxime un
lecteur de gaston l'avait pas avec
maxime pas trop c'était pas trop dans
nos pronos du jour à hâter garçon prend
1,7 à joly c'est pas fini
le crédit kova est terrible non ils
n'arrivent pas la gagner encore pour le
moment tourache quatre tours f4 c'était
joli samaté et papillon puis on prend et
roy h3 et aux reproches qu'à 3 g iii je
crois que ça marchait pas surtout
tourache quatre ans j'ai eu trois
l'entourage 4 lyon prend à et tour f k
tu gagnes et la dame est très pardon
ouais ça gagne à damerey bret pas vu moi
je trouve qu'ils galèrent beaucoup à
gagner des positions gagnantes en fait
les juniors quand tu compare à des mecs
du top niveau comme les carlson mv à les
compagnies j'ai l'impression que les
hikaru etc
j'ai l'impression qu'ils concluent
beaucoup plus facilement bon là
maintenant c'est fini il a envoyé deux
pions des chats persans qui sont
beaucoup plus de mal à concurrents
1200 mieux renoncer juste la première
plage bobby fischer s'est pas pas fake
hein c'est juste la première page
mais oui ça se voit ça soit ils ont qu'à
la jab sol ils ont 16 et 20 ans le petit
indien c'est un bon joueur qui pourrait
devenir top mondial après après jour
arménien non non il est il est un peu
vieux pour arriver au top mes amis joue
pas mal en fait de richard ii quand en
première page des gens qui tapent sur
twitch point tv il arrive sur twitch et
du coup ils sont comptabilisés dans les
gens qui regardent mais ils peuvent
rester juste une seconde de seconde où
ils peuvent laisser le l'onglet ouvert
faut souvent plutôt jugée avec le chat
s'il ya du monde sur une à sur une
retransmission
c'est à 200 personnes sur la
transposition est à zéro mais chasse
dans le chat c'est pareil face est pas
forcé ça peut être aussi mais d'autres
choses mais faute plus tu juges plus
facilement avec le chat en fait il faut
à la fois que sur ce live et je dois
dire que c'est un délire ma écoute
donc mais surtout à 21h07 le délire avec
le match du français en huitièmes de
finale donc damas 8 9 3 mais bon là du
coup il est de nouveau mal
ouais malheureusement martirossian il a
lâché
il a lâché mentalement celle qui varient
vendée si c'est pas du tout la même que
tout à l'heure où il réussissait à huy
réussissent à mettre la pression
tout se joue ce soir ouais on voit que
meyer s ce truc qui est mal foutue là
aussi caméra qui est toute en longueur
et vraiment pas pratique et mentale est
surcoté il a lâché mentalement mais tu
comprends bien ce que ça veut dire
maxime il a lâché le match
c'est pas au mental qu'il a perdu les
trois parties mais là maintenant il a
lâché je pense qu'il a lâché dans ça lui
a laissé le maton 2 et où il n'a pas vu
dame français 2
quand l ofid ils sont 2000 centres de
1600 et 2150
mais là ça se voit dans le langage
corporel qu'il est allé faudrait il
faudrait un faudra un événement positif
pour lui mais les cavaliers dans la
partie précédente il fait tellement mal
donné deux pions comme ça en un coup
c'est une horreur un ouais ça mc soit un
coup de bol pour un évènement favorable
mais vite hein parce que s'il arrive
quand il a moins si c'est fini et
bonjour à mr à la montagne je vais aller
quoi non je n'ai pas 2006 2050
la monteuse veut jouer peut-être à 2004
à peu près j'ai bien loin de 2600 très
très loin tout cas comme j'ai déjà dit
sur le stream ya longtemps sur les trois
quatre derniers toi que j'ai joués je
fais trois quatre perfs à entre 24 et 25
mai on va dire que mon niveau ça va être
à peu près 24 parfaite
que dire maxime c'est pas un coup de bol
sur quatre parties d'affilée cécile à un
coup de bol sur cette partie et on va
dire que la prochaine se passe pas trop
mal il revient à moins de il va se
remettre dedans et au niveau de jeu il
pourrait être à égalité quand y avait
trois et demi trois et demie aller là
leur design qualité prend 1,4 comme
gagnant alors pourquoi on est là on va
le comprendre ensemble puis on prend 1,4
on va dire
tours france et deux tours prend dès 8
heures mais c'est dur à voir dame prend
dès 8 ans pensez deux dames d1 dames f1
et d'armes français de bloquer le jour
il voit ça il m'appelle mais il a fait
tout reprendre et 1,31 qui a valu à 4
qui est pas mal aussi pour être j'aime
il faut un rite ring à 2500 et trois
perfs à 2006 vous c'est ça qui donnait
pas je pense qu'il y avait des fous des
quatre mais c'est très bien ce qu'il a
fait là parce qu'en fait ils échangent
et la tour qui rentrent en c2 il va
bouffer quelque part bon il a pu ont de
plus il ya dame prend 2,5 la halle et
voilà c'est peut-être là le moment
positif talent et ça rime qui fait
kiffer gros cadeau et il peut il peut
regretter les nuls qui l'a pas prise un
hic il peut vraiment les regrettés parce
que les trois nuls qui l'a pas prise où
il a perdu c'est les trois points des
quartiers à quoi ils peuvent achement
les regrettés vraiment il aurait
vraiment pu les prendre et et c'est
vraiment dommage rappeurs comme ici avec
des conditions ouais mais si les
conditions si tu fais les perf à 2006 ça
change ça va être théorique j'imagine
sans voix les coûts rapidement les
parents fous des cinq échecs fou 17
tours c8 qui peut être intéressant à mes
foulées saint qui voulait faire croire
ça toi
j'ai déjà vu partie de carrie akin ya
masse de théorie là-dessus dans le
français 4 serwa g1 puis on prend un f6
et tour c'est un qui attaquent ans et 8
ya masse de théorie là-dessus je crois
qu'il ya eu des mêmes une nulle forcé ou
quelque chose comme ça dans une variante
longue
j'ai déjà commenté un truc comme ça dans
un tournoi bon alors qu'est ce qui va
faire ici ce qui fait un cahier prend
ses six tours prend des 8
non il va juste avoir un pion - c'est
qu'on l'ordi duncan français cissé e5
avec l'idée de prendre en d3 est allé
prendre un set je pensais faire le pion
pas ch
ça me prend 3
ouais en gros l'idée c'est de prendre h7
est repoussé le pion sur 45 dames 3 d'un
machiniste dame prend 1,7 à voir ce que
ça donne peut-être fou b5 et c5 aussi
peut être une idée pour mettre la
pression sur le cavalier puis sur la
case 17 foulée cinq tours c5 aussi peut
exister et la dame chance et que les
parties revers h 6 je pensais qu'ils
voulaient partir vers h six arrières fou
b5 ici quoique fou b 5 fu 17 pays ces
cinq je pense tout à l'heure à cette
idée mais je sais pas vraiment ce
qu'elle vaut
pas vraiment ce que ça vaut tout b 5 fu
17 pays ces cinq jusqu'au idem ça je
sais pas trop ben je sois vraiment parti
comme ça en fait moins 58 non ton ordi
déconne je crois pas à -58 faubel 5 ses
fins
je vois pas dans quel monde ya moins 58
et cavaliers c5 ici pour moi c'est pas
un monde à -58 qui a fait preuve est
celle qui a essayé 5 le retour d'amd 4
bien jouer il peut tout est changé il
veut s'il veut se venger sur a2 là c'est
compliqué comme position on voit niall
qui fait un peu la grimace
et sur foot français si si vos d'armes
français 3 ya peut-être à 4 qui peut
être un coup ouais mais c'est ce qui
vient de jouer et dames france et trois
tours prend ces trois avec l'idée que le
pion il est calme y en a quatre quant à
2,25 un coup c'est le coup de l'ordi
mais j'aurais jamais joué mais à 4 et
maintenant peut-être dames 3 à une idée
d'ailleurs de nouveau peut-être dame g3
pour viser un peu la casse des 6es la
casse g7
maintenant qu'ils échangent qui est des
4 et le problème des blancs c'est que le
roi noire arrivant c'est 50 de coûts
alors que le roi blanc est bien bloquée
ouais tour cité car il y a cinq qui va
faire ici mais je pense ces perdants
après calais prend pions prend fou 17
cavaliers c'est ici sur la france et ses
sciences et 6 3 des 6 hockey et pour ça
il veut faire crisser six échecs trois
des six pions prend est sûre à six
cavaliers à 7 ça qui calcule fou 17 puis
on prend assiste souvent à 6 et le
cavalier enfermé donc il n'est pas parti
pour ça et ça c'est juste foutu ça c'est
juste fou du puy ont pas assez éloignée
fou contre cavaliers jeu sur deux elle
ça doivent gagner tranquillement et le
joueur indien qui va faire augmenter
l'écart qui va repasser à +4
terrible terrible +4 ouais c'est dommage
un pour partir aux six ans qui avait qui
avait qu'il y avait plus ou moins enfin
pas la partie en main mais qu'ils
avaient et qu'il y avait de quoi faire
hélas hélas est mort et sa part en une
demi heure de bus la toile après après
30 minutes de bus la toile pour finir
mais à mais ça sent très mauvais emploi
la foulée cinq sacres au la partie petit
focale sur le cavale et roye b 5 au
prochain
alors il veut quoi il veut roye b 5 3
des cas 3 5 3 des 5 mai au quai le roi
repart et ah oui là bon cavalier c4 tu
es obligé prise prisé ya le pion à
passer moi c'est qu'à 3 6 6 3 5
c'est fini terminé à dos ouais le match
le match est en train de se perdre
le match est en train de séparer il
repart dans la slave assez terrible un
pur pour le joueur arménien si personne
n'a le match est vraiment foutu on l'a
dit un +5 là ce serait trop mais on le
sent on le sent pas dedans voilà khamis
il sema malgré sa victoire qui s'est
bien passé il sait pas il s'est pas
remis dedans
parent mis dedans tant d alexandra qui
m'écrit je vais être obligé de lire le
message
j'ai envie de dire quand alexandra tu
écris les gars tu dis bonjour madame
tu lis le message alexandra qui en
vacances quoi ce terrible c'est
incroyable alexandra qui est en vacances
c'est impressionnant c'est autorisé ça
les amis sabata après le swiss pitch sc1
quand même sa dette en vacances mon bas
qui ce qui se passe là les gens sont en
vacances va falloir que tu interviennent
un les roses ça devant ça devant 365
jours par an et que les années
bissextiles 366,1 hop hop hop va falloir
que tu interviennent bas qui m'a envoyé
non elle n'a pas envie de photos en
bikini mais c'est terrible ça être en
vacances qu'elle me fait alexandre a su
voir son instagram
j'avais juste à moi ça fait quand même
temps qu'elle est pas là en vacances
wayne hall en vacances allant vacances
un mea bon jusqu'à fin octobre c'est
n'importe quoi
tora et est au repos forcé avec les
restaurer mais ces différences à baky
le pakistan sympa comme destination
ouais je suis pas je suis allé passer un
week end cet été franchement franchement
ces belles destinations
l'abbé apc la brigade anti pl autres
professeurs fafa magath qui s'est dit
quand les joueurs sont trop pleutres
avec baky le capitaine que tu vois
maîtres ddb ap dans le chatt signe fait
pitié ni spurs est
qui est des trois prend les 3 merci
merci monsieur faf un professeur face à
tincques y est pas il ya des délires
mais mais tu vas vite apprendre mais
peut-être un fougueux k1 en faut et
quatre sapeurs une pièce - oscillations
phocas a pas vraiment une pièce d'études
revanche sur bare mais c'est super à 6
ça aurait pas bosser au lieu de troller
non ça va ça là bas qui bat qui fait le
taff un ouais je suis surpris au niveau
du score quand même taux cram je suis je
suis déçu un choix fonds pour les jours
arménien toujours jeu très très déçus
d'en bas qui peut pas il peut pas bosser
à mathieu attention un restaurant veut
ferme à 22 heures en ce moment il pleut
c'est compliqué hein
que ferez ton samba qui dans le chatt
images vous prend et froid x h 2
c'est déjà quelque chose mais surtout
progressiste d'un problème 6 dame prend
à sept îles féroé fuite et ça va ils
mèneront cette et pourquoi pas ça sent
ça à partir là dedans je pense
c'est quand le match des petits
tu veux dire de maxime contre gries
tchouk c'est 21h à marquant et dormir
c'est dans longtemps ça c'est le sait le
sata le temps ça tu as le temps ça c'est
pas bientôt sa taverne hôtel 5 6 et le 5
on est malin si c'est le 5 on est très
très mal
je vais te confirmer ça tout de suite
mais à
si c'est le 5 on est très très mal bon
allez faut qu'ils luttent
non c'est le 15 c'est le cas tu m'as
fait peur mathieu qui me fait peur c'est
impressionnant
et menace la tour attention aux
fossettes et damages suite matt donc y
revient bon il n'a pas tué au moins ça a
l'air d'aller info qu'il a gagné allé à
like talent et fouet fuite
allez y défend tout il met les barbelés
allez c'est fini j'ai barbelés de
partout damages cette année on en voit
on revient peut-être avec la dame un peu
et on envoie les lions il faut qu'il
joue vite la halle et martirossian faut
nous faire ton tour de magie il mais la
dame en c3 ça j'aime bien il couvre
aller les barbelés dams et 8
allez on revient n'ont pas d'âme ses 5
c'est moi qui ai missclick allez on
recourt en arrière allez on couvre tout
d'un bep 6 pouces et 5
il met pas les barbelés les gars il met
pas les barbelés à les rois f6 n'ont
peut-être peut-être assister abusé à
lille a réussi à chasser le cavale c'est
un fou qui par angers cette dame prend
3 il défend et cette année c'est cool et
il ya des tours d un pour échanger une
paire de tours il repère à 6 mais c'est
pas si grave tour bessette j'imagine
ouais c'est bien ouais c'est parfait
ouais c'est pas parfait du tout c'est
pas parfait du tout les gars ça pue
complètement maintenant aller cache le
roi allez va cacher le roi a laissé bien
au nom il souffre il en souffrance là
les pièces blanches sont réorganisés en
attaque
les b 4 pouces a laissé bien c'est
parfait
et peut-être 3g 8 x f8 je sais pas si ça
tient à foued 6,3 g set parfait allez
les barbelés là les barbelés les
barbelés
on en laisse pas passer une serait bien
qu'il ait pas il n'est pas impliqué là
et qu'on le voit il est là il a le
regard vide
las le pion b4 ça se voit ça se voit
moins physiquement en fait ça ça soit
réellement physiquement qu'il n'est pas
dedans à 100% assez cool iliad à machin
maths qui revient allez un peu de fair
play
non y'a d'la s'il te plaît allez hop hop
hop on abandonne la halle est parfait
mais je ne le sens pas je ne sens pas
saignant mon en nike là il est passé
gnan
et merci à petit petit coup de polish
les derbys dotons plus c'est très bien
tavernier vidéo de baky et la partie de
talhouët bois y en a eu au tel best-of
il ya eu des choses allaient reste
combien de temps dans la cadence à et 3
minutes 30
acial que gagne ça là il est il et il
est de retour mais il faut qu'ils soient
plus saignant là je suis sûr que je suis
je suis sûr que mon ike en à 100% il le
gagner ce match je suis sûr que mon ike
à 100% il gagne il ya plus investi dans
mes jeux il est il est blanc il est
cerné je ne le sens pas en forme en
haïti y a pas un qui a réalisé cinq puis
on prend des 5 avec l'idée que si tu
prends à non il ya le plus en d3 pardon
j'ai halluciné
ouais c'est bien là ce qui fait b4 b5
c'est une position vous avez beaucoup vu
avec vlad dans un 3 qu'on a commenté ça
être le grand prix de 2 hambourg
peut-être de rigal à jour m'a lâché pas
quoi aucun n'a rien ne peut être en
forme mais j'imagine être car en vrai
franchement franchement je comprends
mais c'est justement pour ça qu'on est
con est d'autant plus déçu edgar c'est
que voilà on a l'impression que les
conditions fond qui peut pas qui peut
pas défendre ses chances à 100% et c'est
ça qui est un peu embêtant ça qui fait
qu'on aura envie qu'ils se remettent
bien avec la victoire
mais à tous rendez a peu joué et même
des ces cinq cavaliers c4 maintenant
rentrés ils allaient cazals il peut la
gagner
ce que les conditions mais si t'as pas
si tu suis pas les actualités l'arménie
en guerre en ce moment ce qui peut qui
suivent pas qu'ils savent pas ce qui se
passe dans le monde
il ya une guerre qu'ils encourent quoi
c'est pas anodin quoi c'est pas le petit
truc ou une grosse guerre mais petit
c'était eux s'étaient dit de manière
ironique
féminines - merci j'ai bien je ne
trouvais pas le mot que je cherchais et
c'était le mot effet mise mais peut-être
tentés mettre un carillon f5 ça pourrait
rapporter un cavalier cet échec un jour
si lecavalier ont réussi à le chasser
et donc voilà c'est sûr que pour ike
c'est pas forcément le
ici on rêvait donc
au courant les gens qui n'étaient pas au
courant énoncés c'est comme ça allez on
voit le quai en dessin qu'il est bien
like allez allez mon petit haïk
il faut faire la diff
c'est le moment de faire la différence
mon petit
le chrono est danois cf qui va rester
une demi heure après c'est la dernière
partie
senghor pas vraiment à profit sur
lesquels il prend h5
mais peut-être
c'est qu'il prend 1,5 et 1,7 qui est
prend ses huit allées les changes en d5
une fois c'est bien ces prêts move et là
il va menacer cavaliers prendre cinq
peut-être et h5 tour prend des huit qui
avaient prend 1,5 aussi à l'esa échanges
price miens il a toujours était mme
paula ait ni continuer mais la grosse
pression à la pendule et d'anne decis
tempo encore jusque là il a tout vu il
veut h5 a rallié prend et alors là la
bad news c'est qu'ils se trouvent que
leur dis dis que ça ça tient pour les
noirs enfin que ça tenait main après
d'un des huit l'ordi donné gagnant d'un
v8 avec l'idée de faire cavalier g6 mais
bon il ya d'amsterdam h5 qui fait peur
après va peut-être le joué par la force
des choses
non il fait dame b 6
ouais et maintenant d'amener un quart et
les f4 dame g4 d'un proche 4 ordi stock
fichtre heureusement il le voit pas on
peut tenter peut-être kg 1 kg 6 d'un
match 5 et j'ai décidé c'est menacer
dame prend aussi ses cavaliers fuite
maintenant il se prend ça il va prendre
le père pète dommage ike qui meurent
avec une minute trente
on sent la déception sur son visage mais
il n'a pas le choix voilà normalement ça
rejoue pas un ouais ouais non avec eux
qui fait des erreurs vraiment inhabituel
pour lui un franchement franchement il
fait des erreurs assez de assez
inhabituel
il est de marbre non non sur la
déception je suis désolé on sent la
déception
il faillit fait des petits gestes de
tête et où il n'est pas du tout comme on
le voit là comme on l'a vu dans les
autres tours
il est beaucoup moins impliqué que dans
les autres matches on sent beaucoup
moins appliqués et on le sent un peu
désabusé quoi même complètement 1
on le sent même complètement désabusé et
maintenant ça passe ambulatoire
maintenant ça va passer au bullet et la
team france joue dans trois minutes way
et maman ça passait au bullet
qui sont les joueurs jura des français
est plus prometteur maori 10 et materia
morelli et materia pour la team france
du coup pour celles qui veulent
participer faut faire partie de la team
france et je vous donne le lien du
premier match qui est ici si vous voulez
jouer et pour la team france je passais
à quelqu'un de la team france dans le
tchat
wen accueilli là il a mentionné
personnes qui soupçonne mais à mais bon
je trouve ça un peu fort de café de la
part de naka mathieu personnellement
parce que pourquoi ne pas le soupçonner
lui en fait dans ces cas là afin tout le
monde de soupçonner tout le monde quoi
je trouve ça un peu fort de café
martirossian a pas forcément des des
résultats plus étonnant que ceux de naka
par rapport à ces partis en réel
je trouve ça un peu peu fort de café
notre petit aicr
petit rake notre petit ricky seuil se
bat bien
bon alors
jamais le lien et ceux qui veulent faire
le match la team france traille à baky
83 qui fut le match la team france c'est
terrible c'est terrible à baky qui va
jouer à wii mais ils ont ils ont pas de
chance en face baky 83 qui va participer
c'est terrible c'est terrible c'est
terrible pour la vo si la bosnie
herzégovine
c'est terrible pour la bosnie bakir 83
et la cua ça fait très très mal
[ __ ] 83 les amibes acquis 83 est inscrit
mon bien redémarré attendait mais on n'y
avait pas le bon désolé pièces comme qui
me fait mettre le mauvais lien normes et
les c-max se reposer brise h
baky 83 mesdames et messieurs qui ne
joueront pas contre le pakistan paye ami
j'espère bien sûr que non donc si vous
faites partie de la team france où est
joué le match
il ya pas mal de gens qui participent
côté côté bosniaque
donc si vous inscrivez vous êtes plus ou
moins sur deux
plus ou moins sûr de pouvoir jouer que
voit jouer avec bâti ce qui est déjà une
belle chose
est-ce que ba qui va mettre le point
malgré ce cas il va pouvoir se remettre
bakiev avait favori selon les l'aurait
bas qui n'est pas favori ouais bah
lessive ou bouger un peu les gars vous
pouvez battre la bosnie ça manque un peu
de savon qu'un peu de joueurs encore
côté français reste quatre minutes pour
s'inscrire
après il ya deux matches que vous devrez
trouver par vous même pour ceux qui
veulent jouer
c'est là qu'on voit qu'il ya pas grand
monde devant le chat car il n'y a pas
grand monde dans le tchat
il faudrait bien un jour de plus ouais
mais après système d'inscription dans
des clubs et où je t'avoue que c'est paf
c'est pas pratique jeunes bovins non
plus un bon il vous manque pas mal de
joueurs
quand même rapporter baky 83 adam parr
les jo bovins c'est quand même pas mal
un petit baky au programme chic et c'est
ça fait toujours plaisir à ja cassoulet
c'est comment il s'appelle c'est
jonathan à bâle à l'équipe l'équipe
commence à prendre forme
l'équipe commence à prendre forme baky
au deuxième et chic et vous regardez
gaston est allé si on réussissait à
avoir un deux trois quatre cinq à lire
est ce si cette place là mais à le
patchouli ne veux pas revenir qui par
écrit talent ça fait longtemps qu'on
voit plus il a peut-être un peu lâché
les scream ou les échecs carrément c'est
à dire combien tu en voilà ce petit
match ça dure cinq minutes puis après il
y en a deux qui s'enchaînent caso et je
pense c'est jonathan duras ou aliments
qu 1 2 3 4 allée cinq joueurs mais comme
ça s'est arrêté sur ton stream web et
bien il vient plus il vient plus par ici
cristal michel cymes de charpentier et
plus par ici d'autant mieux un peut-être
marre de suivra
allez as plus de deux joueurs c'est plus
qu'un joueur et on sera autant
bon après les autres peuvent s'inscrire
aussi si en plus des lots ça changera
c'est à je croise en 3 + 0 vers une
heure du matin
je croise de nuit ils se sont encore
réinscrit aller bosser
du coup vous pouvez vous inscrire à
ajouter des joueurs caniveau tout niveau
là bon mais du coup il y aura encore un
peu de monde près les adversaires sont
quand même plus fort
principe du match va tout le monde je
vous conte tout le monde en fait au
moins c'est simple en v1 cd multiples
inverse une équipe un peu un peu un peu
nombreuses ouais ils sont plus forts que
nous et sont plus forts après ils sont
prenables
ils sont prenables
donc tu mettre les points bas qui il
faut que tu mettes les points c'est
surtout axa va jouer bas qui sait sur
touax à djouba qui le retour de cris
talk et talk qui va jouer du coup à l
envoi la crypte talent qui joue à si on
va regarder sa part si on regarde pas
qui on regarde cristal on regarde
cryptage plus tôt quand même on regarde
quand même plutôt cristal c'est terrible
c'est terrible on regarde cristal on ne
regarde pas vaki ici nous ne sommes pas
intéressés par baky désolé bac iesb
aquis dans le chat de 869 de houphouet
et banque ritalin j'ai passé contre 6 et
du bullet ici aussi c'est du secal ans
bullet ou si ses cadences et façon il
allait même les mêmes dans les deux sens
l'a86 en bullet à il a été à 2005
rapidos et un cryptage quand même y
jouer bien il joue bien failli jouer
bien il joue toujours bien ouais c'est
bullet mais il est 25 60 ans beats aussi
long que ça changeait rien mais là il a
une bonne position cristallin avec les
blancs et la river d'or une position
pas tâche avec le fond ces six bien
placé et s'est fait voir baki où en est
notre bail qui haïssent hub acquis un
baquet en danger on va se marrer dans
son écran à qui on peut pas donner les
coins par contre parce qu'ils peuvent
écouter ça fait combien d'années
cryptage c'est pas vrai qu'il existe
dans le chat un g6
frei viv ces deux têtes de lui coller un
truc va devoir le score du match pour le
moment et toujours 0 0
c'est à rien ça joue serré et donc il ya
2 0 déjà pour la france donc après il y
aura un deuxième match vous voulez le
jouer puis un troisième débat qui s dans
le tchat
on va voir ce que ça donne
baky qui joue sa petite position
tribales qui menacent maths en un
c'était pas assez discret 5
il ya 5 0 le match est gagnable
ce match est gagnable 6-0 ça se passe
plutôt bien pour la team france alors
qu'il ya le match
le match a repris les gars hassar parle
dans cette variante on ira voir après le
score
bats les c cool qu'on a un petit peu
parlé ce a ramené des joueurs qualitatif
ça donne quoi cette position il s'était
retrouvé un peu moins bien tout à
l'heure avec un [ __ ] n'est pas une
cadence way et salue le nouveau du 55
bonsoir à toi benvenuto benvenuto 5,6
peut-être fouache 4 ici pénible ouais
c'est terrible faux h4 c'est terrible le
coup est terrible clouage qui fait mal
un grand classique ça c'est un grand
classique du rire ras du tour des six ou
dix dames f3 pour renforcer et s'est
terminée autour des six était peut-être
plus fort justement ce que ça peut
arrêter leurs cavaliers affichent tous
des six avait clamé et sur dame prend
des six dames j'ai 4 mai d'alger quatre
pattes
well as niall peut tuer le match
vraiment il doit faire tout reprend je
pense sur pions prend kvm et kg 3 kf5 t3
je suis ton g8 allez faut la tenir
1 il a le tour 17 way bien vu ça fait
plus 4 il faut que je remette mon chrono
en place la partie à la durée quoi on va
mettre deux minutes le match là qu'est
en train d'échapper un complètement
aux joueurs à bon joueur arménien baky
qui a gagné d'ailleurs en attendant je
sa victoire de baky quand même qui a
fait un joli matt baky qui met son point
pour garder la fin de cryptage ou si on
regarde un peu tous crient talent qui va
mettre le point aussi à la commune qui
fait mal la commune qui fait très mal à
mettre le point
allez c'est cool et le score de ce match
france bosnie 10,6 pour le moment c'est
serré à 30,32 ils ont pris le devant les
devants parlant c'est terrible c'est
terrible
c'est terrible il avait foi set
peut-être fois je souhaite ici
si fait foi cette saga nié ces faits et
g8
voilà ça ça va gagner tranquillement et
ça va faire le point pour l'équipe de
france
mais bon j'ai l'impression qu'on est en
train de se faire dominer la maintenant
va mater aller le point et me c'est déjà
coulé on va retourner à on va retourner
sur le match
ces mannequins rights official écoutes
bravo à lui
damas 7 et surtout reprend des 3 eyes le
tour a chuté de 8 matt way a laissé bien
jouer avec ça mais c'est pas mal ça roi
b6 pardon mais du coup il ya tout
reprendre et 3 oui il n'y a rien il ya
tour a fui 3 c'est cette dame b3 b6 il a
dû rater en fait ce que sinon ils
l'auraient fait d'armes f4 ou quoi et
dernier set c'était encore une gaffe
nouvelles règles nouvelle gaffe de ike
qui revient au f4 1000 aurifère d'un f4
direct en fait
décevant pour le joueur arménien c'est
encore une partie qui dure en plus déjà
faire dame f5 dame proche 7 et jouer la
finale et rxh et son roi vous jouez avec
ses 5 6 dan des quatre immenses tours d2
maintenant et dame b de maths c'est
terrible ouais et ça fait 5 points
d'écart au le match qui kiffent il
complètement maintenant à cinq points ça
y est on est dans la zone dont on ne
revient pas anormalement bas qui qui va
mater web acquis qui a mis les points
bas qui n'a pas bluffé il s'est présenté
baky qui s'est présentée qui met ces
deux points un homme sérieux un homme
très sérieux se bat qui mais ça va pas
faire gagner l'équipe qui eux qui perd
2,8 points ouais power of tactics rey
qui a fait du power of tactics front alf
cet échec au roi prend et qui a régné g5
terrible qu'un joueur français après qui
à les mater c'est terrible mais on est
quand même mené de 15 points sont trop
forts
ouais ça
milieu de tableau qu'on était vraiment
moins fort dommage
alors on va retourner sur le match avec
ike qui est de nouveau foutu mais si
l'audience d'essence a mieux réussi
c'est juste parce que quand tu as des
premières pages déjà expliqué quand les
premières pages elles partent en fait à
tous les gens qui partent en fait pas
que des gens résiduelles qui reste après
ils ont une minute dix pour jouer ils
ont une minute plus une seconde par coup
à lenovo du 55
pour faire simple
attendez je vais m en titres
j'écris le titre du truc
hop alors qu'est ce qui se passe cette
partie pareil à la la dame de plus mais
albion qui filent et merci américium
pour le pour leur aide
merci à toi voilà il ya le pion qui fils
elias et 8 qui va partir le pion à nouna
chf sur hanouna qui arrive ans et 8 qui
va faire une dame hanouna c'est terrible
c'est terrible c'est terrible pour pour
ike a hélas ou heureusement y'a pas
tomber un mais il va il va se dédoubler
sur la colonne c c'est terrible ça va ça
va encore gagner pour pour le joueur
indien qui revient en g3 avec le fouet
qui va faire tourner 8 m'attend na waie
et ça fait plus six là et +6 points ou
coin qui je reviens des gens pour les
échecs et vénéré écoute merci merci
monsieur mail à six points il reste 20
minutes de jeu c'est il reste 20 minutes
fin foix iii rs est parti mais en vrai
il peut pas fin à ce serait incroyable
qui remonte
là il a déjà filé une pièce en fait le
temps que je regarde le chat que je
regarde combien de temps il reste de
temps à jouer il a déjà une pièce de
moins et il a déjà abandonné se fait
plus est je vous ai dit qu'il n'était
pas dedans avec ça s'est vu dès le début
en fait fin dès le début dès qu'il a
commencé à lâcher sa cellule et la boule
six mois qui a battu la france 88 aka 59
mail à sept points il reste sept parties
max
non c'est terrible mais bon là c'en est
à 100 est terminé des espoirs désespoir
arménien la fin de match va être pénible
ni al zain qui va vouloir assurer le
coup et ont gagné une dernière entre
guillemets chaource dur mais bon je
rappelle à 21h01 le gros match à 21h le
gros match un gris tchouk mvl ça va
envoyer du lourd
j'ai fait un ravitaillement le avant le
avant le gros match alors jean gaston
qui soit se faire éliminer par tim est
beau match on imagine
j'imagine prendre 2 sata team il a fait
douter saphir car ce temps vers 3h du
mat young boys d'après ce que je sais
bon là la position être bien pour les
blancs les noirs m'ont l'air être un peu
difficulté c'est un match au sein de 3 +
il ya plein de cadence ces deux partis
en 5 + 1 3 parties en trois plus un et
cinq ou six parties en plus un pied b6
du coup il prend 17 prend ses cinq
français cinq ans il est gagnant une
nouvelle fois il va sûrement prendre des
fous des trois ici pour contrôler toutes
les cases d'entrée il va ramener le bleu
roi pensaient pas qu'ils allaient faire
ça allait mais il veut la jouer comme ça
ouais ça va aller alors il falloir
contrôler le pion des ouais c est le roi
qui va revenir vers f3 puis vers 3 c'est
ici par logic mois il envoie le pion
beschi hyper logique aussi tu me dire à
moi j'ai pas calculé après quand on
calcule feu trouver mieux et il va
mettre le foin f4 c'est bien pensé
ff ktb huit dames et fouet f3 c'est bien
pensé et ça fait plus huit pour pour
nihal et ça y est là il est là il est
sorti de la zone il pouvait se faire
remonter plus 8 16 minutes de jeu
normalement on sait si partie on va dire
dans un cas très spécial ça peut être
sept parcs non mais surtout que là en
plus il peut jouer la pendule et ses
tournées il ya aucun cas de figure où il
ya il ya huit parties ici
et donc nice à rennes qui va filer en
finale et qui rencontrera le vainqueur
de giang de xiang sarah n'as tu crois
qu'il ya lieu demain nous empêchera de
suivre le norwich est à fond on pourra
suivre que le début mais après j'espère
qu'on sera plus tranquille avec ces
compétitions ça se prononce chang en
fait ouais même pas chiant mais entre
chon ké shon qu'en fait faut bien faire
le jeu en fait xinyang ça rapporte un
joueur le temps a su gagner je crois à
celui-là c'est 5,5 6000 peut-être et
encore mal donc le lien pour le deuxième
match de la team france je mette aussi
aksu le kilo mais si vous souhaitez y
participer
terribles images qui se lance dans deux
minutes on est bien dominé en termes des
deux lots une nouvelle fois et en termes
de nombre là ça commence à être vraiment
chem pour pour haïti qui encore mal le
fou 4 est bien plus fort que le fouet
fin gagne le pion à le pion à 5 avec
tempo
oui juste beaucoup plus fort niall et
dames c-53 chain tourache sissili et
plus wright mais ça fait plus neuf
il en rigole mais tiennent non je pense
pas qu'ils n'ont ils tiennent les os
prépare à manger un ne tienne il a fait
son match
voilà c
c'est du rhin pour ike webo cause baky
baky beau gosse
il va se faire adopter ambulatoire ayez
plus sains et les plus d'ailleurs nous
non plus on n'est plus dans le match et
quand c'est comme ça on va pas reparler
du format bas de façon même même même
ian mahinmi les pulls à +9 +9 il reste
treize minutes
il pourrait quasiment il en est pas
encore au moment il peut il peut partir
de l'ordinateur pour gagner les sétois
la pendule mais à la toute façon les
parties elles peuvent pas durer moins de
deux minutes donc c'est s'est terminée
un ça suffit juste avant le super suisse
où est terrible c'est terrible
on aurait juste le temps d'aller manger
un petit truc et enchaîner avec le super
suisse mais là ça ne s'est pas pas
passionnant cette fin de match on voit
cette fois ci que haïti est gagnant avec
les noirs maynial comme il a le match en
main il va pas abandonner un lui c'est
dans son intérêt de jouer le plus
longtemps possible pour laisser tourner
ça lui ludwig von
la lui veut faire tourner la pendule le
plus longtemps possible pour être bien
sûr de remporter le match mais c'est
bien ça évitera que cai que ne se fasse
adopter
j'en perds 10 d'affilée l'accueil bien
qu'ils aient prend un f2 mais bon c'est
pour ça que quand il ya un joueur qui
mènent ces longs de gagner parce que à
chaque coup il reprend une seconde donc
le temps le maté ça peut prendre
énormément de coups là s'il réussit à
prendre le bus avec le cavalier inquiets
des quatre il peut pas parce qu'ils
auraient cavalli petro a pris du plomb
c'est bien jouer tous ces quatre blocs
le cavale qui ne peut pas revenir
facilement n'arrivent pas à s'approcher
du pion en fait
pu tenter un pat peut-être il y avait eu
quatre échecs j'imagine mais là le
problème c'est qu'il va se rendre
cavaliers c'est d'eux qu'il va y avoir
dames et dames b4 maths mais bon comme
vous le voyez il ay l'a fait il a fait
tourner énormément de temps est plus que
dix minutes il a huit points d'avancé il
a fait tourner trois minutes par partie
donc oui même si l'on gagne il peut en
gagner quatre ou cinq
il peut revenir à -3 aux meilleurs cas
de figure 1
bon allez il reste à un peu des encore
un peu de temps un peu trop de temps
valérie tout ça est quand même très
sympa je vais en profiter pour mettre la
pub tout de suite en fait un peu trop de
temps et c'est un euphémisme
surtout la certainement plus à rien
depuis déjà trop longtemps alors dames 7
et cavaliers g3 peut-être qui pourrait
arriver aussi aller là il rejoue bien
martirossian ou c ou seignal qui a un
peu lâché
c'est plutôt bien en tout cas ça ça
permet que le score soit pas trop pas
trop grave
même si martirossian est passé à côté de
son match va réussir à choper un pion
comme ça des 5 et 6 et 7 des cas tu
comprends pions prend cavaliers à 6 ça
ils auraient ils auraient gagné le pion
à son petit pion de plus est-ce qu'il va
réussir à la mener au bout on sait pas
mais déjà il là et c'est déjà ça
on regardera sur ma chaîne maxime en
finale du super suisse et oui j'ai vu la
réponse de tigran petrossian edgar la
question c'est ce que roy des huit
cavaliers à cette food est satisfait pas
enfermer le le cheval à ouïr paris 6 mai
doit revenir ans émis trois des huit il
va partir de l'autre côté
merci à toi qui j'ai commencé les échecs
grâce à toi et à lui dit il ya deux mois
et je suis un petit mille deux cents
lots beaucoup de saint bonnet lo 1 c'est
pas si petit et là il va essayer
d'envoyer le pion à mes qui doit arriver
après les autres en fait ça doit aller
ballet restera plus que six minutes de
match après une belle sa chasse et dans
20 minutes dans 30 minutes way s'est
pris une focale oui la sphère fou p5 ici
c'est le seul coup qui fait sens dé 6,3
prend à 3,6 maintenant trois baies de 17
sa prise prise d'am-dam mais c'est ike
qui va la gagner
voilà comme tout à l'heure il joue le
maximum de coups mial pour faire tourner
la pendule ce trafic les parties sont
forcément très longue passe comme une
seconde de rage où il aurait pu attendre
pour pas se faire mater mais quand même
une seconde de rajouts ça fait tout de
suite du temps qui revient à sept points
et ben le match est officiellement gagné
il pourrait partir ici
martirosyan yal qui pourrait partir de
sons de son siège et il aurait déjà
gagné le match
c'est terrible
c'est terrifiant
parce que je vous propose c'est
peut-être qu'on regarde jusqu'à
maintenant et qu'on fasse qu'on fasse le
switch après qu'on fasse le way le
switch après cette partie là mais je
pensais qu'il ya deux mois et je suis à
1300 merci pour les vidéos pédagogiques
et toutes les autres merci hawaï a pour
atout t'as pas tout vous êtes des
nouveaux du coup
regarde ces matches pas assez gaby gamme
pas assez la réponse on prouve sa
fabrique et me sens bien dans les 110 de
ses 1100 au blitz ce plaisir inouï ouais
ouais non c'est cool qui est des gens
nouveaux
c'est qu'il prend des cinq on sera tous
hâte de voir une veine jouer nouveau web
on a tous hâte là on est tous impatients
je vous recommande plus l'achat j'arrive
plus en fait là ya plus d'intérêt les
finales s'enchaînent mais un pion de
plus pour pour les blancs ça va être
gagnant mais bon qui gagnent 16 à 15 ou
16 à 9 ou 16 h et pas quoi ça change en
rien l'esprit n'y est plus c'est
tellement un défaut de les faire jouer
comme ça jusqu'au bout ça va vraiment pu
durer une heure et demie de moi cela
paie à l'aise bail qui reste c'est la
pls martirossian qui est vraiment blanc
je comprends je comprends tellement quel
point ça va être difficile
et là il va faire annuler comme dans
celle là mais bon ça change rien finale
2 pions va pas gagner il va échanger les
cavaliers il va faire nul dans la nuit
les proposé par martirossian et sarine
qui fait 7 nuls
ats deux parties sept points d'écart
terrible
c'est terrible on va laisser le truc se
finir petit à petit c'est quoi la
cadence du match au regard du 5 + 1 du 3
+ 1 et du 1 + 1 2 parties trois partis
et six parties d'après ce que j'ai
compris
donc on ce parti en tout
on va tranquillement aller jusqu'au bout
je fais un métier je fais des trucs que
j'ai à faire juste pour juste après
après je vais aller manger un petit truc
j'ai pas encore parlé du marathon de
baigts de 24 ha mais je vais le faire
alors on va lancer le truc je vais je
aller manger maintenant en fait je vais
pas attendre la fin du match sinon je
vais pas avoir le temps de manger un
petit truc
petite question aujourd'hui son conseil
sur le fait de commencer on apprend les
finales en premier quand je lis iman
completing and games faut-il que le lis
complètement ben ali le plus loin
possible le wave pop tout tant que c'est
pas trop dur
bon allez je serai jusqu à la fin de
cette game et on va dire que c'est bon
parce qu'il y aura officiellement il
restera il reste plus qu'une partie
vraiment officiel de chez officiel
il pourra faire fort faîtier forfait non
tu en sais me gêne pas mangé pendant les
streams coup c'est un peu un manque de
respect envers les gens qui regardent
donc on va laisser à et je vais envoyer
le raid
on va laisser ça se termine et ça dépend
de ce que tu manges offert un repas
devant le crime franchement poussé un
peu irrespectueux près ça peut se faire
un meilleur
200 gr ne pas être en manque de
resterait en 200 g ça peut passer
et c'est une nouvelle défaite pour ike
mais bon moi j'ai tout préparer là pour
faire le pour faire le switch c'est quoi
c'est tout reprendre et de le coût est
tombé 3 à tomber un dame prend f4
maintenant on va s'arrêter là dessus
merci arthuis ont fait le switch il va y
avoir leur est tout de suite rester là
il doit y avoir un petit truc pour
cliquer vous devrez avoir le nouveau
live qui se lance avec avec les petits
clips et nous du coup on se retrouve à
oui en fait c'était là d un parti
carrément ils n'ont même pas rejouer et
du coup on se retrouve on se retrouve
dans 15 minutes le temps que je fasse je
fasse ma petite pause a de suite les
gars et 21h donc le match mvl agri
tchouk dans les cheveux je vais même
rajouté nouvelle grippe 21h j'ai même
rajouté l'heure sur le truc et après on
se fait le switch scom france télé en
fait
c'est parti